Four,
three,
two,
one.
We're just talking about moving the
woods together.
It just feels so good.
He'll tiny house with three pairs of
shoes.
Three pairs of pants.
Maybe two shirts.
Yeah,
that's it.
The last clothing you'll ever buy.
One coat.
Yeah.
Everybody's just out here chasing bigger
and better.
Tom,
Papa,
just why?
Why I'm starting to wonder.
I was telling you guys that I was
looking at.
This house is for sale in northern
California.
In the redwoods.
It's 32 now.
Three hundred and 20 feet square.
Tiny ass.
The whole house has got a loft.
The loft is where you sleep in a tiny,
tiny thing.
Below it is like little tiny kitchen.
Yeah,
a little tiny couch area.
That's it.
Like a houseboat,
like with like built in thing.
It's Kinda like A.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They make those.
Now think about how simple your life
would be.
It would be,
but would you be content
that's very small?
You'd be great for a little while.
That's very small.
Three hundred 60.
Yeah.
That's.
I want to shower like that.
That,
that little tiny house.
No,
come on.
That's not the one that's bigger than
that.
That's a 320 foot.
It says three and a 20 foot tiny cabin
in big bear.
Oh my God.
That's attainable.
That's bigger than we need.
It's still for sale.
This video chip in today,
go put up last year,
320 foot tiny cabin in big bear.
Amazing Small House.
So I'm like,
aw,
you know,
we should do Jamie.
So simple.
We should buy that place and turn it
into our big bear studio.
That's what we should do to fucking
show.
I bet the shows up there.
I bet if we did a show in big bear in
the woods like that,
it would have a totally different feel
to it.
Yeah,
because you'd be hearing your guests
screaming in the background,
being mauled by mountain lions,
but if he did do a show up there,
how the fuck would you convince people
to drive two hours?
Could we get there?
People that are training up there or
something like that.
Maybe they could pop over here like four
guys.
Granada love getting Tito Ortiz occur
every day and then you'd be like,
okay,
I get it.
Hey Chuck Liddell.
Canelo's a pussy.
I get it.
I don't know.
I mean the fantasy is that that becomes
a simple life.
You pare down everything,
all the aggravation you get.
Maybe two bills come to the house will
go crazy.
If I didn't have a family,
it wouldn't be a problem.
If it was just single Joe,
no family,
no kids,
it wouldn't be a problem.
I would just go.
I mean I really probably think already I
would already have a place like that up
there where I could just go and chill.
Yeah,
I just that I was thinking of just the
little place like that,
like a little hideout next to the house
like Mark Twain had.
Did he have a place that
little octagon kind of a room and he
would leave his house with his daughters
and his wife and he would go up the
steps and go into his little thing on
this table was just his pipe,
a box of cigars,
his writing pads,
his pens,
and he just would hang out there and
smoke all day and work and then he would
go back home and maybe that's enough.
Maybe that cuts the edge off.
It gives you your isolation and your
simplicity and then you return back to
the people you have to feed.
It's a little something that'll work.
If you've got the people you have to
feed.
If you don't have to feed straight
Woodsboro oh yeah.
Caught up path.
Well,
that's going to be the real trick.
When the kids leave,
when they get big enough and they take
off and it's just Bam to you and your
wife,
and then the wife ones get like five
dogs.
She's probably like encouraging you to
go get a cab and get another dog.
Rescue a dog.
Let's adopt a kid.
They want to keep you tethered.
Well tethered to little things.
They're the nestor.
Yep.
They were the nest.
They if they,
if the nest is empty,
that's their job.
They build that nest once everyone
wanted everyone in that nest safe and
that's what they're built to do you see?
Have you ever seen women that have like
a bunch of dogs when you go like,
you know,
you want a kid,
right?
Like the towel.
I just don't have the time for a kid.
Like how much time are you spending on
these fucking dogs?
Like it's probably pretty close now.
It's just me and my fluffy babies made
my mom and just fluffy babies.
But it.
But what is it about people that want to
further complicate their lives?
Like what is it?
Why?
Why does everybody always want bigger?
Is that just a part of the,
the genes?
Is that what it is?
Like what is it?
Well,
we have,
I think a drive in us to always do more,
explore more,
push more,
right.
There's something built into human
beings that have that and then we have a
system that rewards that in capitalism.
So that's the,
that's the,
that's the board game that we're all
playing,
so it keeps you racing to get more stuff
in bigger house and more things.
You know what I mean?
Like if there was,
if that didn't exist,
if you weren't able to accumulate that
stuff,
what would we be doing?
We'd still be striving but for other
stuff.
But this is our reality.
So the,
it manifests itself in more cars.
A bigger house,
you know,
they were optics.
You're always trying to survive.
But surviving is not that hard today.
Right.
Good point.
So you try to instead,
because it's not too complicated to go
find your food,
right.
There's not a lot of puzzles and
challenges.
Shelters taken care of.
So you start thinking,
you know what,
I just need a new car.
Cars two years old,
28 miles on it,
driving a car with 20
miles.
Smells like farts.
Yeah,
no,
it makes you.
Yeah,
you just keep going.
But then I think you do that long
enough.
You start to realize hopefully that that
stuff doesn't really make you happier.
It,
it does to an extent.
Like when you get out of your poor days
and you kinda like get above water and
you help your family out and you get
some stuff you're proud of,
but then you just are adding more stress
because you're bigger bills and bigger
taxes and all this stuff.
You've got to fill up it.
It actually does the opposite.
It makes you more stressed.
You're not as happy.
And then you got to kind of strike that
balance.
It seems like it's A.
Jim Carrey has been on this kick
explaining that to people because,
you know,
Jim Carey said,
I'm paraphrasing,
but basically his quote was,
I wish everybody would get rich and
famous and they would see that that's
not what makes you happy.
Right.
You know,
people think that,
hey,
if I was rich and famous,
yeah,
would be happy.
Yeah.
He said,
I wish that everyone would get rich and
famous so they'd realize that that's not
the answer.
Yeah.
What does he say is the answer he makes
to make paintings shitting on people,
mocking them.
That seems to make you.
Is that as art?
Yeah.
I know he paints.
I know.
Where's the peace and love,
Bro?
It's aggressive.
Paintings are all like shitting on
people mocking people.
Clearly assholes,
but I mean it's not like he's like
trying to accentuate the love in the
world.
He's just shitting all over these bad
people.
That makes them happy.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
Is that good?
Yeah.
Is it good to focus on the bad people?
Like has anybody changed their opinion
based on Jim Carey's art?
Does anybody know?
I was like a big jeff sessions fan right
till I saw these paintings and then with
Jim Carey's got him with a giant fucking
wart covered dick holding it out in
front of them.
Jizzing all over the constitution.
This little Yoda head.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's always a question.
It's like how much,
how much of art that rails against
something is effective in changing that
thing you're railing against?
Like does it actually have an impact?
Is it a slow impact?
Does it change over time and pens in the
art?
Here's a.
here's an example.
I think Tina fey legitimately changed
the way people feel about Sarah Pailin.
I think she legitimately may have
affected the way people were willing to
accept Sarah Pailin or vote for because
her impression of her was so brilliant.
I don't know if people remember it.
Oh yeah.
It was so god damn good.
She looked exactly like it looked like
her attitude and she said things people
eventually
attributed to Sarah Pailin because they
thought that Sarah Pailin actually said
it because Tina face at it.
She fucking nailed it.
Did.
She's so funny.
Her show a timmy Kimmy Schmidt.
Have you seen that show?
Breakable.
Kimmy Schmidt.
It's one of my favorite show.
It's so good.
It's Tina fey show.
She's in it.
Sometimes she plays the lead is great.
Stick.
I mean,
get the fuck out of here.
That is so crazy.
We're right now the audio folks.
We're looking at an image of Tina Fey as
Sarah Pailin right next to Sarah Pailin
and it's fucking indistinguishable
almost.
It's so good,
but did she.
Do you think she affected people who
already liked Sarah Pailin?
They don't.
If you like Sarah Palin,
you don't know what you like.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Those people like Sarah Palin,
they were out of their fucking minds.
I mean,
they're basically working with a less
than functional brain.
You thought that that was a good idea
that that lady could be running things
like that close to being president.
She was a construct to,
you know,
she was an entertainer,
but not.
No,
but I mean Sarah Palin was a construct.
She wasn't what everybody thought.
She was like.
There was like,
there was one,
there's a story.
I am not hundred percent sure this is
true,
but it makes sense that someone shot a
Caribou and then they drove her to the
Caribou that gave her the rifle and she
stood over the Caribou and took photos
so that they could show,
hey,
she's a hunter like us,
US regular folk out here hunting
Caribou.
Find out if that's true.
Just a public relations kind of thing.
You need to,
we need a google plus.
Believe it,
you know.
Yeah,
of course,
you know,
that's all.
That's the way all that stuff is due,
I believe because I want to believe it.
My announceable.
Um,
maybe she just,
I wouldn't say you're an asshole,
but a good woman.
Yeah.
Hey look,
she was the governor of Alaska.
That's easy.
I can be the government lab for two.
She had showbiz.
Okay.
Sarah Caribou after missing five times
showing shooting Caribou on the latest
episode of a Reality Television show.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's amazing is how that she really
fell off.
Like,
wait a minute,
she's just shooting it freehand.
She doesn't have a rest.
Okay.
Why?
Why would you do that?
Okay,
let me see.
Show this.
Let me see how she does it.
Okay.
This is fucking stupid.
Listen folks,
the only reason to do this,
does she have a rest shut?
She's free handing this.
How?
Okay.
Look at the.
Got The packs on it and now she's going
to rest it.
Hm?
They said a tiny little Caribou to that
care.
That's why the Caribou is still around.
He's just firing.
That's,
that's a juvenile Caribou and she hasn't
shot yet.
Let's see what we got.
And she has.
Yeah,
went down.
She took some shots.
Oh,
she took.
Took some shots and missed.
Yeah,
that's why.
So she freehanded at first and then she
needed a rest.
She should have used arrest immediately
and I've have shot animals freehanding,
but not never far away.
I shot a moose at 60 yards free trial,
a free hand in it because you're not as
accurate.
W with a bow?
Well,
a bose more accurate.
Honestly,
a bow,
a more accurate with a bow at like 60,
70 yards.
Freehand.
Not more accurate,
but in the range that I am with a rifle
with a rifle.
When you get out you could shoot
accurately on arrest,
like way out longer distances.
But when you're just holding it up like
that,
it's based on.
I mean you've got to kind of lock it
into your body,
but it's hard to but isn't a bucket
steady now bought.
The thing is about the tension of the
bow.
Your arm is kind of locked out in the
tension of the bow.
You could keep your arm pretty fucking
steady and I practice it everyday like
that.
So practicing keeping my arm very steady
everyday.
So all these stabilizer muscles in my
shoulder are very strong.
And having a gun out there,
it's just like let's just a little so
and also the recoil if you're not used
to shooting and it doesn't look like
she's used to shooting the.
She didn't immediately go for the rest,
like a seasoned hunter would have either
lane prone or throw their pack down
immediately put that rifle over it and
settle in.
So rifles resting on something.
Gotcha.
You know.
But a lot of times they'll bring like
sticks but they pod fail somewhere
making a reality show for Tlc.
See.
But what I've read though,
that there was a photo shoot,
they did see it,
see if you can find this fake.
Do you think that the thing is fake?
Well they just put a circle around them,
but that's just for the,
for the filming.
The caribou definitely went down.
Yeah.
But I mean I don't think she shot it and
it went down.
I think it's most likely she shot it and
it went down because you see the way
she's reacting and everybody else's
reacting.
That seems pretty real to me.
Like,
it's not impossible.
Shoot an animal,
especially that's a juvenile Caribou,
that she how old their antlers are.
He's like,
hey guys,
what are you doing?
This is what you would call it.
Like if that was an elk,
you'd call that a spike.
Hey look,
it's people.
I'm just thinking about the production
here.
Like there's one camera on her and then
there's one behind them,
but that means that,
that then have a third that's focused
just on the animal and that means
there's three camera guys out there with
them.
That's just sounds like a lot.
Yeah.
And the camera is like,
Hey,
I'm going to be on TV.
That's a good point.
They might have recreated the shot.
It's bomb.
It's possible.
Yeah.
It's,
you know what man?
The reality is whenever you're dealing
with air quote reality shows,
there's massive fuckery involved and
editing and please,
but uh,
back to whether you could affect it,
whether or not the art can affect what
you think.
Yeah.
I mean,
what trump did during the election,
he like calling people out and mocking
them.
He really thinks that art it,
that's not her,
but he was kind of like a,
like a long island
comedian,
like a insult comic,
you know,
it was just like going after these guys.
Crazy Ted and little water guy and I
mean he was doing.
It was very much entertainment lion,
ted,
crazy.
Hillary,
Bernie,
crooked hillary and Hillary and crazy.
Bernie's going to defend.
Teddy said at a big rally defendant.
Yeah,
he stays for what?
For the Texas?
Uh,
things in what you're talking about,
pat.
I'll pull it up right now.
This isn't a race right now with the.
I forget the guy's name.
Is Betty overwork or patio.
Now pull it up.
Okay.
So He's defending him.
In what way?
He's going to have a big route.
He's gonna hold a big rally for
Pocahontas.
Is that after they talked so much shit
about each other,
then they go cruise.
So he said yeah,
after he says his father was killed
Kennedy or something.
Zodiac killer.
We're doing a major rally for Senator
Ted Cruz in October.
I'm picking the biggest stadium in
texts.
Fine.
As you know,
ted,
as my complete and total endorsement,
I like how he was endorsing with a
capital e.
his opponent is a disaster for Texas
week on Second Amendment Crime,
borders,
military and vets.
He's,
you know,
there was an article yesterday showing
all the Times that trump has been lying.
It's stunning.
But one of the more recent ones was,
uh,
he was,
he did,
uh,
an interview where he was talking about
God dammit,
Lester Holt,
Lester Holt.
That's right.
It was Lester Holt and you know,
he was saying that they fudged that
interview and it costs them badly.
And so then they played the transcript.
They wrote,
they showed the transcript of the
interview.
They released the full interview.
Like there's no fudging.
No.
It just played it as is.
You're like,
what are you talking about?
Yeah,
he,
but he,
he said that he's.
He says,
what you saw is not real.
The truth is not the truth.
Well,
that was what Giuliani said.
Yeah.
But that's.
But that's what.
They're just.
Nothing's real.
Except what I tell you his real well,
I just think that they've realized that
there's a certain percentage of the
people that are with them that just need
some wiggle room.
They just need somewhere or argue they
just need some consideracy threat.
They're not thinkers.
They just need a little bit of something
that they could run with and use to
argue.
So if comedians come out and attack
trump and you know,
there's comics that are,
you know,
Bill Maher and all these people that
come out and really go against them.
Does it have any effect?
It has an effect.
It does for sure.
I think Alec Baldwin has the most effect
that,
that impressed.
He doesn't impression of him.
That oppression is brilliant.
He
makes trump angry to trump,
keeps shitting on him.
He keeps watching it.
He can't stop watching it.
That alone has an effect.
Yeah,
but it's not.
It's like I've never seen a time where
people are more angry at the press and
like,
uh,
going along with the conspiracy thread
of the deep state,
the deep state trying to take out the
potus.
I love what they call them.
Potus too.
It's fucking Donald Trump.
Stop.
No,
no,
no.
Potus is this and that.
He's going to do this.
Including the swamp.
Like what?
Donald trump.
Why?
Why are you saying Potus?
Just say if you want to say trump,
that's fine.
You want to say president trump?
That's fine too.
You want to call them potus.
You're doing some sneaky shit.
I'm not sure what you're doing.
Like anytime you use codewords,
I'm out.
Likely you're doing agent 99 minus.
Get outta here with potus.
Potus.
How he wears a hat that says 45 on
45th.
President had his own hats made.
Who the fuck?
One of the presidents had hats made.
He has merged excelon merge.
After the show,
I'm going to be signing in the lobby in
the lobby.
I got painted caps.
Bumper stickers like looking for a gift.
Is this the trump?
This is a good way to get assaulted.
Positional merchant.
If you just wear one of these and a
Vegan restaurant,
you're sure to get punched
this scene.
Oh my God.
Guys going to get indicted.
The guy that pulled the hat off of some
kids and threw a drink on them in a
water water burgers.
I would.
It was the guy in Texas.
Yeah.
Some um,
some dude saw some there.
He's got the 45 hats.
Whole areas official.
It's only $185 to $50,000 by a stupid
time.
It's unsafe to be 28.
Now it's 1680.
You can get my DVD.
You can get a bike,
you can get a digital download of my
speech tonight and you go from $28 to
1680.
Like I want to be in the room with that
conversation.
Do you want to charge 1738 and no less?
I'll tell you.
16 92 close to 17.
$40.
Oh,
it just says USA.
It must be a good seller.
USA.
Does it get that trademark back?
That is fucking hilarious.
40th five in the side.
Tromping back $40 for a hat date.
If they find that you bought that,
they put you on a very special list of
morons that they count on whenever
there's a rally.
Like if they're going to like have a,
like a fake hillary in a jail cell and
they're gonna throw her,
threw a parade.
Like have her on a cart and carrier
Oh Man.
You don't want president pence.
Listen,
you know,
I mean,
people that are not happy with trump got
understand.
You get him out.
It's not like you get Hillary in.
This doesn't work that way.
It doesn't come out of the hallway.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Wouldn't you rather have pens?
Um,
I know people say that,
but I just want,
that's somewhat normal.
I want someone that whole pants is not
normal.
You see what Ben Ben Shapiro wrote,
he put a tweet up with a picture of the
lady from the handmaid's tale when deep
trouble and he wrote,
prepare for pence.
Fucking religious nut over the top won't
be alone in a room with a woman.
Yeah.
How about Romney?
I just saw him on Jay Leno's show.
He seems like a reasonable car.
It looks very presidential.
Cool.
President hair.
I gotta be honest.
He seems.
Romney seems like a reasonable man.
Seems kind.
He seems like he respects.
He's a natural.
He's a nutty Mormon for sure.
You know why?
Because all Mormons are nutty.
More than just being a mormons.
Nutty.
They changed the name.
You don't call them Mormons anymore.
Talking about that yesterday they
rebranded.
Calling them a mormon.
It's like calling a small person.
Image.
Midget.
Oh,
is it?
Yes.
So a compliment.
No,
I keep forgetting what to call him.
Adorable or so.
Not Pc.
Are you on twitter?
Good luck.
You need to get on PC.
Twitter.
Hey,
can I announce my new show?
No,
come on.
it's not worth it.
It's big.
No,
it's too dangerous.
You spawned it.
You're taking a chance.
Why are you doing this?
I know,
right,
exactly.
I'll be fired before it starts.
He announced the show on Rogan and then
it was canceled by the time he got off.
They were talking about midgets.
They're assholes and Mormons are
wonderful people.
It's true.
Once you have a boss.
Yeah.
No,
my show starts Monday night.
The bread show?
Yeah.
What's it called?
Baked.
Ooh,
I like it.
It's baked.
Look at that.
Handsome.
You look,
it started here,
Joe.
The whole thing started here.
Smile.
It's like I'm happy,
but you know,
pretty serious about bread.
The real reason I do that.
I look awful.
What I just showed my teeth.
Hey,
you look great.
I got this weird joker smile.
Now you've don't do it if you just
embrace it.
I called that bread behind you.
I know.
Isn't that amazing?
I'm in Ketosis right now.
Well,
I knew that the show,
the show starts this Monday night at
10:00 east and we were doing New York
and Detroit.
Jim Gaffigan joins me in the New York
one.
It's all very cool.
So every Monday through September,
all because of this show.
And you're bad ass fans.
Honestly.
That is why this is happening because I
talked about bread on this show.
That's fucking great man.
But I knew you were in a,
probably in Quito and.
But you know,
I always like to bring a tree.
What's this?
I didn't want to uh,
come empty handed.
So sticks of butter.
It's for Murphy.
Oh,
it's bone marrow.
It's elk.
Oh my goodness.
So elk antlers for.
Can I eat this?
You can't know it
all gets for Murphy.
Marshall.
I thought it was.
He'll go crazy with these.
Yeah,
they're a.
that's like one of those.
My dog went crazy over those.
Did you ever give.
Give you dog?
Yeah,
he's got one at home right now.
Yeah.
He's got some sort of an antler but
loves it.
They go crazy,
but just chew all the marrow out
overtime.
You look so happy when you're with your
dog.
Oh,
I love that.
Don't you look so happy.
He's just a pure joy and the dog looks
happy.
He loves running and you know,
you can get a dog out in nature.
He's so and he's like the best dog I've
ever had in terms of like listening and
coming to you and always checking to
make sure that because he's a retriever
know,
so he's like super in tune with you.
He's,
he's so fun to like.
When I come home the first thing he
does,
he sees me,
wags his tail.
It comes up to me and then he runs,
grabs a toy,
puts in his mouth and then comes back to
me like he's retrieving something.
He has these instincts to bring
something to me.
My black lab has the same thing,
same thing.
I always feel bad that if I don't have
time to like play and start tugging with
her because she's just like,
you're here,
let's go,
let's play,
let's do when you don't have to work and
you get on the phone or whatever.
And they just like lay on the ground.
Like
I came home or an adult the other night
at like 1:00 in the morning from the
comedy store.
And uh,
I sat on the couch to start writing and
a marshall just comes over and goes to
what's going on,
what do we do?
And it's like,
like a roommate,
like what's happening in Europe.
It's crazy.
Everybody else is asleep.
They've been asleep.
He's just gonna fuck around the laptop.
All right.
I'm gonna lie down right here.
I just slide down.
It's the best.
There is a great feeling when you're
writing and the dog is right next door,
right?
So fucking far tit.
You like,
Whoa,
dude.
You eat a rat outside or something would
happen.
I hope he enjoys the elk.
Thank you,
man.
That's awesome.
You're welcome.
Yeah,
he's the best best talking about Rod.
Well,
Johnny cash was an awesome dog to.
Let's look at that face.
He's just lying on his.
Yeah.
So happy.
He's such a happy dog.
Yeah,
my dog would be happy like that.
If I could find some good trails.
I don't have good trails.
I just take them to a runyon or
something.
You know,
he.
Can he just run up runyon?
Yeah.
You just got to be careful of other
people's dogs.
Like Marshall got bit by one.
Someone's dog wants.
Some people just have dogs that just are
not that well.
Uh,
you know,
socialize.
Yeah.
But if you,
uh,
you know,
you have a model leash for the most part
or you find a good spot where you don't
have to have them on leash and that's
great.
It's just,
that's what I want to do.
Other dogs or the issue and snakes who
rattlesnakes rouse thinks you have to be
very careful around,
around us.
Out here.
You guys go up,
you're running dog gets bit by a
rattlesnake.
Take A.
you're a quarter mile from base camp.
It'll be okay.
Dogs be way better off than people can
run back with him.
Yeah.
You take them back home.
I mean,
I might have to carry them because it's
really steep.
The stuff that we run on is like
literally like super fucking Steve.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's uh,
it's basically the last three quarters
of a mile.
It's all uphill who?
Yeah.
And it's fucking brutal,
but it's great on the legs,
in the ass.
Fill my ass,
my ass.
Happy Labor Day.
But I thought when you got hit by a
Rambler,
you're supposed to like not move.
Now you got to get out of there.
You've got to get to medical attention.
You got to go.
What it does is,
here's the thing,
you can't suck the venom out.
This is what people think.
People Think,
oh,
you just cut it and suck the venom out.
This is what rattlesnake venom does.
What it does is it digests your skin,
it digest your flesh.
The venom does.
Yes,
it causes necrosis.
So would it would essentially is doing
is digesting you with venom and this is
the way they kill rabbits and things
with the eat and swallow.
They bite them and then they kill them.
Does Venom and it starts to digest the
flesh and then they swallow it whole and
it aids in their processing of this
animal who.
Wait a minute.
So the snake hits a rat.
Yep.
If he were to take his mouth off after
five minutes,
would it have been partially digested?
Is that what you're saying?
That literally starts,
starts digesting.
Yeah.
It starts,
it starts decomposing and digesting.
So when you get bit by a Rattlesnake,
a lot of times you need massive skin
grafts and um,
you have massive tissue loss.
And necrosis is one guy documented.
He got bit on the arm and they had a med
vac amount and the helicopter.
And then he had to go through a long
series of operations to repair his arm.
She's like Mesh and skin grafts.
And all these different things and it
still was fucked up.
Like years later his arm is fucked up so
he didn't get medical attention.
Why would you die?
Well,
like what?
It would just spread through organs.
Don't exactly know you.
You might survive a rattlesnake bite if
you're going to get medical attention if
it wasn't the most amount of venom.
The real scary thing as young ones.
Young young rattle snakes just empty out
on you.
Just like young boys,
you know first like,
Whoa,
where's all this coming from?
Even storing it up.
You don't know how to control it.
The that's how it is with the older one
trap.
Like 80 year old man.
Have you ever know the difference
between like an 18 year old fella
shooting arc as Bill Hicks would say?
Arking ropes of Judaism versus a
rattlesnake that's like thick.
Like a fucking.
Like a tree trunk.
Yeah.
Those.
I ran over one month.
This was crazy.
I was running with my,
not the last dogs that are deceased,
but my dogs before that,
when I used to have pit bulls and we ran
over what I thought was a a large stick
in the road and the trail,
and as I'm running over it in the air,
I realize it is a giant rattlesnake.
Oh,
thick.
As my former.
Oh my God,
it was huge.
Seven feet long.
He's just in the middle of the trail,
just completely stretched out like a
stick.
Oh my God.
Just sunning itself and the dogs ran
right over it and it didn't strike you
to just know.
The dog's luckily listened to me and
they weren't aware that it was,
but those dogs were crazy.
Those dogs had been bitten three times.
Oh my God.
My dogs have been bitten three times by
snakes,
so they knew they just killed the
snakes.
They didn't give a fuck.
Pitfalls are so crazy.
They're the craziest dogs.
They're so hard wired for combat.
Like the rattle snake was in the paper.
It was like,
fuck
that killed him.
They didn't even worry for a second that
he got bit in the face at one time.
He got hit,
bitten the face.
He got bitten.
The face of.
This is Frank Sinatra.
Is there a name that time he named the
dogs.
The craziest dog I've ever had.
A dog killed everything he could.
His main game was I leave him in the
yard and he tried to kill lizards,
his main games.
It was like a video game who just walk
around the yard,
stomping on the grass,
looking for lizards,
dive on.
It was like,
it was like a game to him.
Just trying to find lizards to kill.
How was he with people?
He was wonderful with people.
Was a sweet,
sweet.
Never strike out.
Go after a person.
No,
no.
He never been a person.
He was.
He was a little aggressive with his like
he wanted to play and it will freak
people out because he would like to play
and pull ropes with you.
Like he'd want to grab a rope and bring
it to you and have you pull on it and he
would make these horrific noises.
So you'd.
You'd be pulling it
and people were like,
what the fuck man?
I'm like,
he's just playing.
He's a sweet dog.
Let go.
Give him a cruise with quantum,
blah,
blah.
Right,
right.
Crazy kisses.
But he was so.
They get a bad rap though.
They deserve it.
They deserve because you don't know if
you're just walking down the street and
you see a pit bull off leash.
People should be cautious.
People don't want to hear that because
they love their dog.
My dog is different.
Don't say that they are bred to fight.
That's what they're bred for.
That's where they came from.
That's where the breed.
Yup.
No bullshit.
The reason why there's such great dogs
is because they're bred the good ones,
at least to have no aggression
whatsoever towards people so that when
the dogs are fighting,
they could go in and separate them with
no fear of the dogs turning on the.
On the owner.
Interesting where they do this.
Ireland,
America,
but America.
That's.
What do you think?
American pit bull.
That's what it's called.
American pit bull terrier.
What do you think the Michael Vick thing
was all about?
Right.
There's a been around for a long time
though.
I haven't been over 100 years or a
couple hundred years,
but the,
you know,
that was originally going to be our
national animal before they went with
the Eagle.
Ben Franklin sell the Eagle.
I don't know.
I didn't even notice the idea.
It was who wanted the pitbull.
I Dunno.
I mean they use it as war dogs when they
use them in,
in the army.
How would have been a cool symbol?
Sort of.
But you know the,
the,
the problem with those dogs is multifold
one,
they have a very high prey drive.
Like they're their drive to attack
things is very high and the more they're
bred for that,
the better.
The more intelligent they are,
the more intense they are and people
love them because of their intensity and
their intelligence and their loyalty
towards their owners is outrageous so
that love is deep.
That's why.
That's why the pimple people,
because they really do.
If you say anything,
do they get really up in arms about it?
They just,
they don't want them to have a bad rap,
but I love those dogs.
Don't get me wrong,
but one of my dogs killed one of my
other dogs.
Oh really?
Yes.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You can't have two female pit bulls.
You can't have that two females.
They'll just go and just.
They never sorted out.
They never decide who the bosses.
They decided that they start off like
they'll,
they'll figure they'll have a fight and
then one will win and then you say,
okay,
well in normal situation this one
realizes that it's the Alpha and then
the other one will back off and no
fucking way that with girls they won't
quit.
Girls never quit to go back to it.
What if one of them was hanging out with
Marshall?
Other?
You'd be fine.
That'd be fine.
She was fine with my male dogs.
It was.
It was a female dog.
She wanted other females around.
She was not fine with my mails.
If the mail was getting attention and
she wasn't,
she would get angry like,
you're stealing my attention as well.
She was a prison dog.
She was.
She was in the lab animal shelter for
many months.
When I got to Brian Collins wanted to
talk to me and again,
he goes,
dude,
you got to get this dog.
He goes,
I can't get her.
My yards too small.
He goes,
dog is so amazing.
So sweet.
And I went to see her and she was the
sweetest dog to people.
Was it a puppy still or still got her?
Yeah,
she's still a puppy,
but she was amazing,
but they're just fucking dangerous
around dogs.
Yeah.
My sister had a uh,
a bull mastiff.
Oh,
those are great.
Great Dogs.
That's so kind to people's like loving,
like you put them with children.
I mean it's a big dog.
It's head as like our heads combined,
but other dogs,
other small dogs really it was bred for
that and it would go and just any dog on
a leash with an old lady attached did
not care and just pin it to the ground.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And you just couldn't get it out.
I mean that just in the breed.
I had a dog that was a massive that just
died and I just had him.
His name is Johnny Cash.
We just had to put them down when walk
anymore.
He was 13 and I'm like,
this is the saddest moment.
Like the last week of his life,
Marshall was in the pool and he was
jumping around and playing with my
daughters.
Nobody's having a good time and Johnny
wanted to come to the pool but he
couldn't walk over there and so he
would.
It would take a couple steps and you'll
be panting and his legs would be shaken
and cable take a couple steps and he's
panting and his legs shake and he was
just in agony.
So I picked him up all 140 pounds of
tons of big dog.
Every time I run man,
I start coughing.
I ran this morning and then for the rest
of the day I'm like,
when I try to talk,
I got like your throat.
It's the,
it's the dirt.
I'm breathing in dust and pollen and I'm
in the bottom of these canyons,
running through all this shit and the
dogs in front of me kicking up dirt.
I'm Iran on the concrete today and I'm
making.
My point is I carried them so I had to
carry them over to the pool and I,
I sat down there and he just laid down
there and he was smiling and pants.
He was totally deaf by the time he died,
like completely deaf.
Acute would be lying there.
You'd be like,
Johnny,
you hungry?
Johnny?
And then he touched me like,
well where'd you come from?
Oh really?
Bummer about big dogs.
They die so well.
13 is not that bad.
It was amazing.
They actually died at like nine,
eight,
nine.
They're ready to go.
And what?
So I can't.
My dog's about 80 pounds.
And uh,
you know,
it's a big presence.
One hundred and 40,
that's a big thing in your house.
And to know that it's,
you fall deeply in love with it and then
it's gonna be gone in six,
seven years.
It's hard.
If he was the sweetest dog tag,
everybody,
dogs,
people,
everybody just does the giant lovable
recently had to put him down.
Oh yeah,
a couple of weeks ago.
I'm sorry.
That's.
Yeah,
it was rough,
but it is rough,
but it was really hard seeing him
suffer.
Like when I try to bring them in.
Well,
the last year was rough in the last
couple of months it was,
when do we do this?
It was like,
when do we,
when do we put them down because I don't
want to come home and find him dead,
but for a year we knew he was kind of a
slow deterioration,
like couldn't walk him anymore.
That was about two years ago.
Two years ago.
I just couldn't walk them because where
I live is a lot of hills.
You just couldn't do the hills.
He would just take a few steps and have
to breathe heavy and they take a few
steps and have to breathe heavy.
I was like,
God,
Jesus.
I didn't think he was going to last as
long as he did.
That's good.
That's a good life.
He was the best and that was a super
sweet dog,
like always sweet and kind of like he
could be eating a steak and you can come
over to them and you could take the
steak from Louisville who would never
growl at you.
Right?
You let your dog in the pool.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Why not?
I don't know.
I think it's going to be all wet and the
house.
Fuck out of here.
Dry them off,
bro.
Dogs love to get dried off.
When I.
When Marshall comes out of the pool,
I pulled a towel.
He was like,
Oh yes.
He comes over and I robbed them and he's
like,
Oh yeah,
chlorine or salt water,
salt
jobs it because I get one of them big
beach towels
and throw it over and I just start
rubbing them down.
Loves it.
He sees that towel.
He comes running in.
He's like massage time.
What about all the hair and the pool?
Yeah,
there's a lot of hair in the pool.
You have a scoop that up?
Yeah.
It comes in clumps.
Retrievers find it at the bottom and it
looks like algae growing on the bottom.
It's nasty hair.
I've been keeping my dog.
I've been keeping my dog of the man.
Why would you do that?
It's La.
It's hot as fuck.
Let the dog swim.
Jesus,
man.
Yeah.
Oh,
here in the pool because I take a
shower.
What are you worried about?
Water?
I don't know.
It seems like a pain in the ass here.
Dirty water.
The here's what about coloring?
Can I get that?
I'm a dog.
Skin.
Is that all right?
It's on your skin.
Just wash them off afterwards on down.
Why would you worry about the dog and
not yourself?
Jesus.
I only worry about myself and not the
dog.
Why don't you get a salt water thing for
your pool?
So yeah,
it's a whole rigmarole room.
Yeah,
but it's not that hard.
Now I know.
I got him.
I'm working on other projects.
Him.
He's just one of those guys that
dismisses important things in your life.
It's not true.
It's just that in the back.
So when I get high,
I think about it incessantly had fucks
with my head.
Is that what happens to me?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's the number one thing.
We get high and then you realize,
oh,
I haven't been thinking about this at
all.
And then when you're high it's the only
thing you're thinking about.
Oh,
for sure.
Things that I,
I,
you know,
should have been thinking about like a
year ago,
that sprinkler.
How much is that leaking water?
How much water is at league and what
have we run out of water?
Then I have to think about all the
sprinklers.
Brokenness.
I should just do it.
What's wrong with me?
Why can't I just make that goal to make
that call me out lately?
Emails.
There's no way I can keep up.
It's impossible.
Now at this point,
do you have a number that you try and
stay below in your inbox?
No.
That's how I do it.
If I can stay,
if I,
if I'm under 75,
I know I'm a,
I'm on top of it.
Seventy five.
I'm gonna.
Show you something that's fucking hair.
Spin
that number.
Where are we?
Upper left,
4,000,
655 in one account.
Good luck with those.
Is that also your garbage account?
That's just.
You're.
No,
you're good man.
No 1000 emails.
What?
Yeah,
exactly.
What are you doing that to yourself?
How are you going to do that?
It doesn't weigh on you.
Nope.
Come on.
Doesn't feel like a cluttered desk.
Well,
I have more than one email account.
Uh,
you know,
business from managers and close
friends.
So that's.
And then this one for people that have
known me forever,
you know,
and then there's business one for people
that I don't know that well,
you know,
that I'm like in my inner circle,
but that's,
that's like,
that's a lot of emails.
It's a lot,
but you're important.
One is your inner circle and your
business and that's not 4,000.
That's a lot.
Hundreds,
hundreds,
hundreds.
In a lot of it's nonsense.
It's all nonsense.
But then you feel like you can throw it
out.
Yeah,
if I could just keep it.
I have a garbage account.
I have,
I mean my one account that is.
Yeah,
you go down there.
Oh,
that's not bad.
Ninety
9,978,
but that's because I have an aol account
that I just.
Anytime you're in a store,
anytime,
whatever the game.
Can you sign up for something?
Can I have your email?
It all gets that and that's why it blows
up.
But my private account,
my inner circle,
one under 100.
That's where I'm staying.
You got basically about 4,000 big Dick
pill.
Yeah,
exactly.
Try this cough drops.
You know,
will keep me from coughing.
His cough drops work.
I can't.
Yeah,
they do work.
It doesn't.
I'm not coughing unless I'm talking when
I'm talking.
I just feel that in the back of my
throat.
It's right at it's,
it's like two hours after running.
Always.
Yeah.
Up Up to two hours.
Maybe you that it sort of goes away.
It's like my body to run with one of
those masks that they wear at the
airport.
One was,
it's here anyway.
No,
no,
I'll be all right.
Let me try this coffee.
Some coffee.
Yeah,
I don't think that helps.
Coffee generates phlegm.
Hey,
I saw an article this morning.
I wanted to get your thoughts on it.
Okay.
Uh,
I was reading about a that they're
thinking about putting a video gaming in
the Olympics.
Yeah.
And the way they were talking about it,
they're like,
this is inevitable.
This is going to be in the Olympics.
And these,
uh,
kids consider themselves athletes.
The only hangup that they had on it was
it the video games are violent and they
don't want to promote that.
But to me it was like,
well,
wait,
is this really a sport?
This is the Olympics trying to cash in.
That's all that is.
I think
it Olympics are dirty.
I think it's a dirty business.
And this was highlighted by the movie
Ikaros saw that movie and you realize
how uh,
the IOC is in bed with the world
antidoping agency and how,
you know,
how they sort of functioned together.
And what it really is all about is
making money and anything that
compromises that making money,
they're going to vote against it.
It's just,
it's not,
it's a dirty business.
And if they did have it in the Olympics,
what they would basically do is take
these guys who were making millions and
millions of dollars playing video games
at a professional level.
Yeah.
And millions.
They would make them work for free and
then they would make all the millions of
millions of dollars.
But it's say,
Yay.
You get to be in the Olympics.
Dirty business.
I think the Olympics are dirty.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
Well his chest in the Olympics.
No.
Why been took wrestling out.
But chassis.
We're actually moving pieces around
video games.
Just icons on a screen.
Like why?
What?
What do you mean?
They took wrestling out.
It took wrestling.
Aba.
They took really took wrestling out of
the Olympics.
No,
no they did.
Yes.
They did know.
I love wrestling.
And they took it out.
They might have brought it back,
but it was gone,
right?
Jamie?
No know wrestling's not out of the 11.
Yes.
They took it out.
There was no wrestling in the summer
Olympics.
Come on.
I'm not kidding.
For Real.
That doesn't make any sense.
I know.
That's crazy.
Why wouldn't I never heard of that?
I know there were.
There was at one point in time they were
talking about it,
but I thought that thought it was put
back in.
It was the same.
It was out for at least one and 2013 ioc
voted to drop wrestling from the summer
Olympic program.
Effective 20.
20.
Is that real?
Yeah.
I don't know if it's happened yet
because it's supposed to be for 20,
20.
I don't know if it's.
I'm pretty sure it was in the Olympics
in the summer.
It was not 21 yet,
so.
No,
but I mean the last Olympics that he's
saying it wasn't in.
I don't think it was.
Yeah,
I think it was.
I don't think it was called Bob Costa
column.
Now.
Bob.
Bob Is your icu ward.
Bob was on an episode.
Newsradio kicked my ass.
That was the episode.
Oh really?
I thought he was hitting on this girl
that I was dating.
He beat me up.
Yeah,
there it is.
In the Olympics.
I guess Tom Papa's wrong again.
Oh,
that's from the seventies.
Look to see that guy.
See that referees can
go look at that guy,
Jesus Christ,
96.
Go back to that and they took it out.
All right,
so maybe it was in last time,
but it's not.
What the fuck you're looking at.
They voted against it.
Now he's trying to look jacked.
He isn't Jack Weightlifting back then.
Let me tell you something,
bro.
That guy's not jacked.
He's jacked.
Pure.
Let me see it.
A little of this.
If the Greco Roman introduced in Athens
in 18,
96 going on here,
the grabbing each other by the underwear
is a different kind of wrestling.
That's ladies
Buhler is a rough fucking sport.
Oh my God.
I would have found this though it
they're adding um,
video games to the Asian Games in 20,
22 and then it's gonna be a
demonstration sport in Paris.
Twenty,
24.
What's coming?
Well,
wrestling,
those guys don't need it.
You know,
and this is my message to anybody who's
a pro video gamer.
You don't need those people.
What do they offer?
They offer shit.
They want you to work for free.
They're going to make all the money.
You were already huge and by the way,
the people run that.
They missed the boat.
They didn't see it coming.
They don't deserve it.
What about the athlete part of it?
What about it?
Do you consider it a sport?
Well,
no,
it's a game,
but it's a very highly skilled game.
I mean it's definitely something
valuable like the.
He used to be thought as a frivolous
waste
of time,
but now you can make legitimate money
with it,
but you don't.
I don't think you classify it as a
sport.
I mean they call it east sports.
Are they an athlete?
Is it,
is it is the top Gamer and athlete?
The only caveat is that it's hand eye
coordination right there.
His hand eye coordination and what do
you consider a sport?
Do you consider something?
You move your entire body or it's just
moving your fingers enough because his
pool of sport.
Billiards.
Is that sport?
I don't think it is.
I think it's A.
Yeah.
It's a game that requires hand,
eye coordination and control and touch.
Tennis is a sport,
right?
Yeah.
Tennis requires full ankle being full
mental being.
Yeah,
you're.
You're running around,
you're jumping back and forth,
you're swatting that ball.
They're shooting at you.
Trying to get out of the way.
I mean the the amount of endurance you
have and stamina and explosiveness all
contributes to your game.
Would you make an exception for someone
that's really good at Cubert?
Yes.
That was my favorite subway surfers in
subway surfers and my daughter plays
that shit.
She's a little wizard.
It's a.
it's not a sport.
The only one in the Olympics because
they realize there's massive amounts of
people that are watching it and playing
them now and they could make a lot of
money in arenas.
I mean they're,
they're gonna.
They're filling arenas in Olympics.
The live part of it is a billion dollar
business.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of sports that are
in the Olympics had no one gives a fuck
about if they're not in the Olympics.
Right,
right.
Like,
like that curling,
curling the ski shoot one.
The skeet shooting one with a call that
full on or pentathlon or.
Yeah,
there's the one that Bruce Jenner one.
Which one was that?
That's the decathlon.
Did he have to shoot shit now?
Throw a spear or something now?
He did the Javelin javelins part.
Technically a spear,
but okay.
Is archery archery's in the Olympics?
Yeah.
Is that a sport?
Um,
that's more of a sport,
right?
You're using your full body.
Well not really.
I mean you are for stability,
you're stabilizing with your legs and
you have a certain stance and if your
bows heavy to pull back then it requires
strength,
but that's a,
that's blurring the lines.
It's just the scent.
I think archery is essentially a martial
art with a tool,
you know,
and then you're demonstrating but you
could do it on paper.
So it's target archery,
target shooting in the Olympics.
Well,
as part of skiing.
Right.
And I think they do both.
They do it in summary reaction girl that
was just targeted.
Yup.
Just shooting,
right?
That girl you were telling me about.
Yeah.
So That's interesting.
I mean that's close to a video game.
Not really.
No.
Video Games are.
Well,
I guess maybe,
but like we were showing,
showing that Sarah Palin thing,
which she was trying to shoot offhand,
totally hot,
holding the gun up.
That's um,
if you like,
that's more of a sport if you try to
shoot offhand or pistol shooting,
I would say like pistol shooting would
definitely be a sport.
Like when they do those courses,
you ever seen those courses that they do
for training?
Ready Go.
Light goes off and then you run through
a door and then you turn a corner and
tight,
and then you die.
And some are bad guys and some are good
guys.
And then there's a bunch of different
ones they do and some of them are just
targets and some of them are targets
that are dressed up like people,
right?
Yeah,
that's more of a sport.
Well that's a very physically demanding.
Like you ever seen the candle reeves
footage.
Now he's training for John Wick two.
Now please God make John Wick three
stuff with them running through times
square on a horse,
shooting people in the head in John Wick
three.
They're already doing it,
you know,
we'll just show the footage.
First of all,
the training footage for John Wick.
John Wick two.
Man,
that mother Fucker,
Keanu Reeves,
he gets into it.
He was training with my friend.
He can Machado in Jujitsu.
So they do rubato no,
here he is.
Look at him.
Give me some volume.
So like when you watch him shoot in the
movie,
he looks very comfortable shooting and
even his martial arts,
like the stuff that he's doing in the
movie,
it's legitimate.
Like it's,
it's doable.
It's real.
He's really training.
Oh yeah.
I mean he's not doing anything where
you'd go get the,
like there's no road house moves like
house last night.
I love roadhouse.
I got home from the comedy store last
night and it was going to go to sleep,
but roadhouse was on like,
fuck,
I'm standing up.
I stayed up.
It's the best gun in the bar.
I watched it an hour and a half in until
he killed the guy by grabbing his neck.
That's when I had to go sleep.
Um,
you missed the big end scene in the
house.
It's good enough.
Song I saw enough,
but um,
so he's on a horse in John Wick three.
He's the real deal.
He's like Tom Cruise.
Just get back on the Chevelle.
Why are you giving them a horse?
He's Tom Cruise.
The 1970 Chevelle is the way to go.
Not a fucking horse.
So he trains like legit shooting trains.
Legit shooting,
legit martial arts center.
Jackson is in it.
Yep.
Oh my God.
Samuel Jackson not in.
Is there a list of like 10 films?
Start being an actor until he was late
in his career and his age.
Oh yeah.
Just read the summary.
So how old was he?
I want to say 40,
but I feel like I might be mixing them
up with something that might be Rodney
dangerfield.
Um,
yeah.
The original.
John Wick is a fucking great movie in
John Wick Two was a great movie.
They're both great.
I watched two of them back to back on a
plane recently.
Is that the one where everything's on
fire in that one scene where he's like
coming out of an apartment twos one when
he's fighting that Ruby rose chick is a
fight with ruby rose.
Will Laureus
Girl Power?
Save it?
Save.
It.
Takes such a good punch.
Yeah.
KIANNA's pulling.
Pulling punches.
Yeah.
He's legit.
Tom Cruise.
He trains and does all his real stuff.
Yeah.
Tom Cruise does a lot of crazy stuff.
He fucked up his ankle.
Jumping off of a building to another
building.
Yeah.
Climate on the outside of planes hanging
on and does all that stupid shit.
Car Chases.
He does that and does it himself in
Dubai.
Hanging off the end of that building.
Guys.
He's a maniac.
He is a maniac.
I wouldn't just fighting off them.
Scientology demons were using angels.
Angels are just Eton's.
Dayton's are the bad things.
Those are things that stick to you.
Right?
I thought that was where like your soul,
like that's who you are.
You are eaten like in the shell of A.
I thought the themes were like the bad
ones that came in.
You had to fend off everything.
I know about scientology,
I learned from South Park
from that a long movie I learned to
Code.
I learned a couple of useful things from
learning about it.
Going clear.
Did you see going clear with
documentary?
Yeah.
Do you read the book?
No books crazy too.
I read some of dianetics though.
I did too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I read it when I first moved to La.
I bought it or ordered it on late night
TV.
Yeah.
I wanted to.
I wanted my nephews to get to join up.
Just see what would happen.
What do you hate your sister or your
brother?
Who was one of us has got a Brit kinda
being a pioneer here.
Let's go see what this.
Does one of us going to join the cult?
Yeah.
It's too late for me to get in there.
See what happened.
Have you seen wild wild country?
Yeah.
In reading his book,
the Art Osho his book,
the art of living and dying.
Oh yeah.
It's very interesting.
He knows what's unique about him.
Is that the things that he's saying or,
or like legitimately profound and very
interesting and like legitimately deeply
philosophical,
like you're reading it and you go,
okay,
this is a,
this guy was a real thinking person and
he was like deeply considering these
things from all sorts of different
angles and yet he allowed that crazy
Sheila lady to run his call and poisoned
people and nations.
But even before that he was collecting
rolls royces and he was like,
he was,
he loved the love luxury.
The problem.
Look,
a lot of people have good ideas.
They try and motivate people.
It starts out like these nice
intentions,
whatever.
Once they taste money,
that's it.
It's over greed.
It just takes you over and you can't
shake it.
It's like,
why would I be in a,
in a,
uh,
for tourists when I've had a Rolls
Royce?
Well,
how about just one rolls Royce,
Bro.
I know,
but these people need to power power and
greed.
It's,
it's and celebrity and then you can't
shake it.
All these televangelists,
when all those televangelists wind down,
like they start off like preaching
around the south dirty,
like in little churches.
Then they started making millions of
dollars and it goes off the rails.
Greed,
demon.
I'm telling you,
there's.
I guess they're similar.
I mean because like that guy from what
you're saying,
he has some good points is some good
stuff.
There's some stuff in dianetics that's
makes very good sense that.
Hold on.
Don't you think that all that good stuff
is negated by a love of objects?
I think that it ends up corrupting them
and they start making other choices that
don't align with what they're preaching,
right?
Yeah.
I think it's where they're human beings.
We're all human beings and you start
getting that power and then all of this
money comes in and it was rough sex.
There was also a lot of sex.
A lot of sex.
Cult was a lot about just free sex.
Everybody banging everybody.
It's funny how it all comes down to
those things is always becomes sex,
money,
power and celebrity.
That's a potent comp.
Like they all fall from those things.
Desires these great benefits to all
those things,
right?
Sex feels great if you have a lot of
money,
you can buy awesome things and you enjoy
them and you feel like you've
accomplished something if you have a lot
of celebrity than everybody kisses your
ass and he would walk in the room and
his hands class together and everybody
would go crazy.
But it's a different kind of celebrity,
right?
It's not.
His celebrity was not just like,
oh,
there's Tom Papa,
dude.
I love your bread show.
It wasn't that.
It was.
You have.
The answer is oh,
well that's.
Yeah,
but that's the,
that's the ultimate power is celebrity
mixed with God mixed with the answer to
that guru,
that power.
Now you're off the charts.
Well,
you get a little bit of that in yoga
classes.
There was a yoga class that I used to go
to where the guy who was the instructor
was banging some of the students and uh,
he was slimy.
Yeah.
He was like,
you could tell he would sing in class,
like sing songs and be like,
Bro,
you are killing my buddy.
Yeah,
I'm out of there.
And you're so white,
like everything about it.
He was just like,
he was a,
uh,
a slippery guy.
Like in his thing was being this,
this really spiritual yoga guy,
his 40 year old women whose husbands
retired a fucking them.
They would really,
you know him.
Next thing you know,
he'd be given them privates,
air
bowel checkup.
I,
he would probably talk to them about
sensuality and of course in their aura.
And then probably lay some shit down
about,
you know,
one of the main problems in
relationships is there.
The Passion sometimes ebbs when there's
a loss of respect and appreciation for
each other as individuals as unique
soul's.
Yes.
I'm experiencing that in my
relationship.
I'm so sorry.
So sorry to hear that.
The boundaries of intimacy should not be
related,
is it me?
But I feel like I'm seeing the real you,
that no one else sees boundaries in
intimacy should not be confined by a
piece of paper.
You know,
I mean,
it's obviously that the vows of your
marriage have already been broken by
your husband who's not nice to you
anymore.
Let me write down the apartment.
My apartment in Encino,
sweet yoga,
Dick Brown,
Brown walk around barefoot everywhere.
The hot yoga guy touch with nature.
The hot yoga guy.
He got busted for sleeping with all
these women and was the hot yoga.
He fucked everybody more than that.
He was accused of sexual assault.
He wasn't.
My guy wasn't sexually assaulting
anybody who's just slipping the Deq in.
They were allowing it.
They wanted the deck like there's a
difference,
you know,
but then there's some people that it's a
power move,
but some people say that that's abuse,
that the,
the,
the Yoga Guru who manipulates the woman
and then foxer that he is in a way
definitely being guilty of sexual
misconduct and perhaps even something
more egregious because there's a
relationship that they have between the
guru and the student and he's violating
that trust in that power dynamic.
Yes,
that's Catholic church,
but.
Right.
I mean it's the same.
What do you mean?
Forty year old married woman in a
fucking yoga teacher is not the same as
a little kid in a priest,
but it's using power for them to get the
same thing.
Oh No,
it's not.
One of them is rape and abuse.
The other one is a lady wants Dick.
Well,
you didn't say she wanted to
touch her.
Just twisted this around and apologize.
All those yoga teachers out there
fucking their students.
Now that's a violation.
If you're a guru,
anything that's a teacher and below
you're using that,
you're manipulating that person.
Okay.
But wasn't that like a big part of like
a undergraduate students and professors
back in the day?
They can't do that anymore.
Yeah,
that was a big thing.
No,
in my high school,
the basketball teacher ended up marrying
like his best girl basketball player.
Hey,
happy ending yet worked out.
Oh,
well how old was she beating him?
He was probably 30 something and she was
17.
Whoa.
When did they get my basketball?
I don't know.
After school.
During school now.
Apparently it was Doris and then they
ended up.
Was illegal then?
No,
no,
no.
In many states it probably was legal in
Jersey.
Yes.
I guarantee you it was what year?
Nineteen 85.
80 seven.
Guarantee it was.
17 was legal.
I bet it was legal really.
I bet.
I bet 16 was legal,
right?
Yeah.
And that's not to say that there can't
be a happy ending when somebody is the
teacher or for the quarter on your side.
I mean it's definitely a violation,
but it is manipulation.
What's the age of consent in 19 eight?
Note New Jersey.
Age Sixteen years old.
16.
Yup.
Wow.
I could have hit on this crew.
Okay.
But hold on a second.
Consent for sexual conduct.
16.
This applies to both heterosexual and
homosexual conduct.
As a general matter,
this means that a person who is 16 years
old can generally consent to have sex
with any adult.
And this is in 2018.
That's today.
So here's the thing,
here's the thing,
like,
you know this Asia Argento thing
going on right now.
So the 17 year old kid when he had sex
with her,
it was in California.
So he's saying it's sexual assault
because she had sex with him and then
she got Tony Bourdain to pay this kid
off.
Three hundred plus thousand dollars to
shut his mouth.
And then it came out that she was a
hypocrite because she seduced this kid
and fucked him and she had played his
mom and a movie 10 years prior when he
was only seven,
which is really kind crazy.
There's pictures of her and the kid when
the kid was a like a little kid,
she stayed close to him and called him
like her son and he would call her mom
and stuff like that.
And then they got together and she lied
about it and so she didn't fuck up.
And then pictures came out of her in bed
with them.
And then her friends released text
messages.
She,
she's a fucking monster in a way.
Was he of legal age when they had sex?
This is my point.
He was 17 at the time,
so it have been totally legal if this
happened in New Jersey,
but it happened in California,
but this is all going on while she was
making a big deal of Harvey Weinstein
having sex with her when she was 22,
like Jesus fucking Christ.
I was crippled.
Chris,
you know,
the whole thing is crazy.
But my point is,
first of all,
let's be honest about that situation.
I mean seventeens,
he's going to be okay that I'm just
saying,
even if it's illegal,
it's just not the same for boys.
It is not the same.
Should she have done it?
Probably not.
Yeah,
definitely.
Probably not.
Should she be locked up in a cage for 10
years for doing that?
Now?
She's a freak,
right?
That lady is a freak.
She was.
He was 17,
but she's more guilty of being a
hypocrite than anything.
Did she stay in touch with them all
those years?
She was playing the mom,
yes.
The real creepy pictures her in the
movie with him when he was like a little
kid,
but it's not as creepy as woody Allen
when he had his daughter sitting on his
lap and then 10 years later that same
daughter is holding his hand as his
girlfriend in a brand,
in the front row of a basketball game.
It's kind of weird.
Think that's a little creepier.
That's why that is so weird.
I don't know if you even a reason to
make that comparison,
but the point is that kid would have no
case at all if this was in New Jersey,
right?
It was in New Jersey,
which I don't think he should have a
case.
Does he?
Is he prosecuting like
or he.
He apparently threatened to go public
within.
He wanted money and they gave him money.
Anthony Bourdain did and gave them a
lot.
300,
$380,000 and even after he got paid,
he comes out.
That is the most expensive dick that
lady will ever get.
Then he comes out,
comes out.
It came out anyway.
I don't know why it came out.
I don't know who released it.
Harvey Weinstein,
somebody.
Somebody released it.
I don't know what happened,
but what they're basically showing is
that this whole thing,
you know,
of her attacking being attacked by
Harvey Weinstein.
It's complicated.
Maybe he did exactly what she said he
did.
It's possible,
but she clearly is deceptive.
She definitely lied about this kid.
The problem is the age of consent being
17,
if it was 18 or if it was.
If he was 18 rather,
or if it was like in New Jersey where at
16 there's no case and she just fucked a
young kid and I'm just going to be
honest.
The only thing that's creepy is that
they had this sort of mom's son thing
going on with.
They talked about each other as mom and
said,
that's weird.
If she was just a hot 35 year old who
had sex with a handsome 17 year old boy
seventeens as a man.
It's not the same thing.
If it was a 35 year old man and a 17
year old girl,
she directed the movie too.
Does that change?
Yes.
She directed the movie,
the new one,
the movie 10 years ago when he was a 17
year old or a seven year old rather.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
You know my,
my.
She was 37 when she was seven.
She was seven when he was 17.
She.
She didn't make a move when,
when he was seven though dose.
She was waited until he was 17.
She's a good person.
Yeah.
She,
when she got close to the wire,
she's like,
I can't hold on anymore.
And then for ready,
it's will you move to New Jersey?
I won't over here.
Here's the issue.
I don't.
I just don't think it's the same thing
now.
I think the only thing she's really
guilty of here is hypocrisy and
deception.
I don't think she's guilty of a sex
crime even though she technically is in
my mind.
I mean,
maybe I'm.
Am I a sexist?
I don't know if I am.
I'm sexist against men.
Well,
I just think.
I think the guy's going to be okay.
I just don't.
I don't buy that.
He was so damaged,
but I knew that he was,
that damage from her.
He would have been dead.
He would have been damaged from a girl
who was his age too.
Who fucked him and then didn't call
them.
Right.
That's the thing.
Emotions.
That's not a crime.
You know,
you hear it,
you hear this argument.
It's like,
well a boy can be effective for sure.
Everyone can be affected.
And when you're 40,
you know,
in some of these instances where the
teacher sleeps with the kid and it's a
boy and he's 14 and people are like,
oh,
come on.
He would love it.
He's,
he's a boy now at 14,
you're still don't know who you are.
You're still mixed up.
And again,
we're a teacher student dynamic.
It's a different situation.
She's stipulating you.
Right?
So
the question is,
is this dynamic equal to the teacher
student?
Because she was the director and she
played his mother and she clearly had
some sort of a maternal love like sort
of relationship with him early on.
And then it became sexual later.
But then she says he jumped her.
She says the Horny kid jumped me.
That's what she said to her friend when
she's being honest.
Yeah.
So maybe he did.
Maybe he was in love and pining for the
whole time.
Maybe that's one of the reasons why he
came out and wanted money in the first
place to trying to get back at her
because she didn't want to have anything
to do with him anymore.
And maybe they had a couple of drinks
together and she,
you know,
she just didn't know what to do when he
started making moves on her and so she
fucked him because she's crazy.
That's possible to know.
What is it?
Is it a crime?
I mean,
what you're telling,
you're talking about a crime where if it
was 200 days later,
it's not a crime.
Like really is he going to learn a lot
in 200 days?
Laws the law.
Joe,
the law's the law.
Mr. Dragnet over there.
You gotta pay you gotta you know the
laws are on the books for reason.
Joe.
And then launch says 17 doesn't say 16
and a half.
[inaudible] 17 for region johnny lawyer
over here.
Well it really does.
That's what it comes down to it.
It's like we,
because it's so gray and because there's
so many things that can happen,
you really have to be come down to what
was their last.
Have to pull your pants down.
How much premiums you got.
Let me see what you got.
How big your deck,
your full ground.
The fuck out here.
Pussy.
That's not fair.
I remember 80 bang,
I had a friend of mine who grew hair
when he was 12.
He was a little Italian kid.
He had a mustache full team.
I'm sure his pupils were gigantic.
Good
Asia Argento go fuck that guy.
He couldn't help it.
He would get a haircut and would grow
back by the time he got in the car,
he was just Italian.
Yeah,
it's complicated.
You know.
The thing is
she had a consensual sexual relationship
with Harvey Weinstein after the alleged
incident where he ate her pussy and she
didn't want him to.
Well that's like the cosby thing.
They keep coming back.
There was a couple that came back and
don't wait a minute.
Were they aware that he drugged them the
first time?
Uh,
I don't know the details.
It sounded like it sounded like they
knew something was weird,
but then they came back anyway.
But you didn't like
exonerate someone from a rape just
because after the rape you're friendly
with them.
Right.
Because you know,
it's a big mental impact.
You don't know what's going on with
these.
Just that it's some people they want to
mitigate the effects of being raped by
turning into something different.
So they made me would establish a
consensual relationship with the person
after they rape
them to try and take their power back a
little.
Well,
not just that,
to try to relieve themselves of the
feeling of being a victim.
They almost make it consensual.
There's like a weird psychological
dynamic that you and I will never
understand as men will never understand.
And now because it's not the same,
it's just.
No,
it's not.
So if she went back,
you know,
with Harvey
woman can't comes over your house.
Right.
Okay.
If you're a single guy,
am I in a cabinet?
A little cabin,
a little tiny,
$320.
It's,
you're in big bear.
You weren't there,
you weren't flannels and you're cutting
wood.
Okay.
And a girl comes over and she sucks your
Dick against your will.
Don't stop.
I can't believe you're doing this.
God Damn it.
And then once it's over,
you're like,
well,
I don't want to feel like I got raped.
I'm just going to establish a
relationship with this lady.
Would be like,
shut the fuck up Tom,
Papa Kid Outta here.
It was that Michael differences because
you're a guy.
You're not worried about your physical
safety.
This is the real issue.
Physical Safety.
I can't get pregnant.
I used to work out with his gay.
Jim used to work out at Gold's gym on
coal and I say gay gym because it was
just like a lot of gay guys,
like really obvious overtanned,
you know gay guys were like super thin
tank,
top muscles,
fucking combat boots and real
aggressive.
Yeah.
Leather fucking paper Boi.
Hats on and mother working out.
I had a friend can gay,
but my point is while I was in there
working out,
these guys would hit on you right now
and you'd feel like,
guys,
we're looking at you and hitting on you
and it made you uncomfortable.
Well welcome to being a woman and not
even really because I could fuck those
guys up.
So I wasn't worried.
Like if a guy tries to go to the parking
lot,
I'd be like,
hey dude,
we're good.
This is going to get violent.
Stopped trying to fuck me right now.
Like I can actually fuck you up,
whereas if I'm a girl I have to worry
that I'm fumbling for my keys and these
guys behind me in the parking lot and
they want to push me into the car and
take my pants off.
This is a real concern for women that
men don't have.
So our ideas of what it would be like to
be in a non consensual relationship with
a woman where she sucks your Dick
against your will.
It's just not comparable.
That's a great point.
Michael Douglas movie came out and it
was the same thing.
It was the reverse.
I forget which movie was he?
She goes down on him and he's like,
no,
stop it.
It's a work relationship.
And he's like,
stop down little attraction now.
It wasn't fatal attraction.
It wasn't behind the candelabra it was,
uh,
it was another movie and it became like
a thing.
It became like a,
like a joke because as a disclosure,
because as,
and who was the star?
Demi Moore.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So she goes down on him and everyone
they were trying to make the case that
it could happen to a man to the culture
was like,
now god,
here it is.
Yeah,
she's a predator.
Predator,
I'll leave
this.
Shut up.
Get off.
Wrote that a fantastic sex thriller.
Masterfully done.
That's fake news.
Wrote that.
Well,
good for them.
Putting it out there and giving it a
try.
Kelly always have that like fucking wcn
TV.
Some Shit you've never heard of wwe.
Oh RTV.
Fuck out of here.
What is that like
for any quote whatsoever?
So they just take some wonky quote from
the Boise News station.
Some guy's drunk when he writes out,
he's barely paying attention now it's
just someone with a blog.
It's like dawn's movie hut.
He loved it in the middle of the forest
when they were.
When I was watching road house last
night,
he put a cassette and this is Mercedes
car is playing music,
shoved in the in there and play.
And I was like,
yes,
fucking kiss.
My daughter got a cassette from one of
her friends,
a cassette player looking for cassettes.
Yeah,
get them day or something.
Yeah.
Yeah,
like she has a punch,
but they're really pretty obscure.
This is a real concern that everything
that we have is digital,
you know,
and that we're moving to kindles and
ebooks and all these different things,
and then he downloadable music and less
physical music that anything that
happens that wipes that stuff out,
that wipes out their ability to play it
a deserve.
The recording we lose every.
There'll be gone forever.
All information,
all of our information is becoming
digital.
I becoming more and more vulnerable.
We're becoming more and more aware and
more and more educated that were risk.
Like we're.
We're more aware that we're being
attacked,
like people are trying to steal this
stuff and we're putting more of our
faith in it.
Yeah,
but what I'm saying is as we become more
educated,
not even with that,
just the more information we
accumulated,
the more vulnerable that information
ends.
It's not like books that are like locked
solid and they're always going to be
there as long as you keep it in a
fireproof container.
No,
this is our.
Our knowledge itself is way more
vulnerable than it's ever been before.
Yet way more advanced.
It's interesting.
We've been before.
That's really interesting.
Fucking weird,
but isn't it all backed up on the cloud?
What does that mean?
I had Dr Robert Schoch on the podcast,
who's a geologist from Boston University
freaked me the fuck out talking about
coronal mass ejections from the sun and
that what what they believe happened
somewhere around 12,000 years ago.
There was some sort of a gigantic solar
event that caused lightening storms.
You know,
like when it's a storm and rain is
coming down from the sky,
like fucking buckets of rain everywhere.
He said it was like that with lightning
and the lightning literally turning the
ground and the glass and certain places.
How long?
Who knows?
Mass extinction of animals.
Really mass extinction of people like
just lightening raining down on the
whole planet.
It wasn't my gun off.
He's right.
Obviously it's a controversial theory
that he was proposing,
but it's based on what they believe
possibly happened with a coronal mass
ejection from the sun,
which can and does happen and has had
passed.
I always think about that,
like,
what's going to stop like a giant
asteroid?
All of a sudden
they're happening all the time.
Yeah.
It's just not big intensity,
but why not?
Why not have one buildup and last I seen
a comparison of the earth next to the
sun.
Yeah.
When they show the solar flares are
hundreds of times larger than the earth
itself.
It's so crazy like,
but it's far away,
right guys?
It'll be okay.
We're still gonna have a barbecue this
weekend.
Couple million miles.
How many miles is the sun away?
How many million?
There's the.
Yeah,
the moon is $200.
It varies.
It goes a little closer.
A little further away,
but somewhere around 200.
Sixty thousand.
Two hundred.
Ninety 3 million miles.
The Sun.
Yeah.
Let me pull up a comparison.
The Sun in comparison to the size of the
earth in you,
you realize like,
Oh,
a million times bigger.
A million times.
Million Times bigger than the earth.
Yeah.
Boy,
that's a big question.
Say a solar flare pops off.
If it's that far away,
you're fucked.
Depends on how many know about it.
Know it's coming for awhile.
You have a couple minutes just.
Oh,
that's going to look at that.
Look at the one point $3.
Billion earths.
Oh Geez.
Look at the earth though with a little
dot
right there.
Oh there.
Oh my God.
Now look at those ejections.
Look at those flares.
Oh no big.
Those flares are.
And then look at the size of the earth.
Like those.
That's common.
That's every day that's happening all
the time.
Have you ever seen video of it?
It's fucking amazing.
It's crazy.
It's amazing.
Like what's happening on the sun right
now?
Should freak everybody the fuck out.
And it varies.
You know?
It's like,
it's a giant nuclear fireball.
Yeah.
It's just a constant nuclear explosion.
Oh my God.
Look at that shit.
It looks so hot.
What a shit design,
right?
How are you going to heat everything up?
We'll just put a big fucking fireball
and the sky.
I mean it's basically like a,
like a fireplace.
How crazy.
How crazy that it works.
So good.
It's crazy work.
Yeah.
Well,
it's one of the arguments that really
dumb people use for religion.
Like what are the odds that all this
worked out perfectly?
That we're this close to the sun.
I mean,
come on,
man.
Scientists are trying to keep the
creator from EU.
Japan is trying to land in unmanned
robot on an asteroid twice the distance
of the sun.
It's a 186 million miles away.
Whoa.
It next month,
next year,
next month.
They're going to be.
We're going to try and land on it.
Raced the Japanese.
I didn't even know they were in this
space game.
It's orbiting it right now apparently.
Well,
the Japanese have the hymn of worry.
Eight satellite.
That takes gigantic high resolution.
A full photos of the earth from 22,000
miles out every 10 minutes.
Somewhere around then.
Oh
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
pull that up to him of worry.
Eight.
What are the.
What's the details of the memoir?
A,
it's one of the best things to use
against these flat earth dorks.
Like for the longest time,
one of the things they were saying is
that there was no full photos of the
earth from space that everything was
just stitched together.
They don't know.
Jack Shit is so fucking stupid.
It's such a scary stupid theory.
Real time is real time.
I look.
It's nighttime.
How far away is the distance?
The hamawand say I think it's 22,000
miles.
Him a worry.
Eight.
That's a satellite.
The satellite is 22,000 miles above the
earth and it takes real time.
Photos every 10 minutes and high
resolution.
They're like massive,
massive photographs,
but they use it to predict weather and
you can like.
You could literally see storms coming in
and share so bad ass at it.
Look how he zoom in and zoom out.
Know I had no idea the Japanese were
doing all this.
Oh,
they're on the ball,
son.
They make the best cars.
The cars don't break your fucking around
with these teslas.
That shit's going to run out of
batteries in the desert.
Gonna be stuck.
You're going to be with chapped lips
like a Mad Max movie.
Just shuffling,
trying to get to Nevada.
Trinity's trying to charge my car with a
phone.
I have credit cards.
You could have.
My credit cards is giving me water
from California,
so I'm kind of queer here.
It worked for queer this up.
I'm just listing my footprint.
Electric car guys.
How'd that work out?
Where your conflict minerals.
Electric car.
You paid shit.
I just tried to be nice to have a planet
guys.
How could those cars not run on solar
power?
That's what I don't get.
Especially in California.
Like everything.
Solar.
Why don't you have a solar roof panel
and so on.
The car itself,
you regenerate the battery hood should
be solar.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
Oh my God.
Look at all the known asteroids from
1999 to 2018.
What?
Whoa.
Fuck.
We live in a shooting gallery.
Look at NASA is identified more than
18,000 near Earth objects.
They're just floating around all three
rate.
Hold on back that up again.
The discovery rate averages.
What did it say?
Forty per week.
It's asteroids.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
Back Up.
Chance of a large earth asteroid hitting
earth is slim.
What?
But scientists will continue to monitor
all known near Earth objects for any
potential collusion with us.
They say with slim,
you know what?
Until you know,
I was talking to this one sign,
look at that,
right?
I was talking to this one scientist and
he was like,
well,
you know,
they already have plans in effect if
they find asteroids.
It's not something that I'm concerned
with.
They're already thinking about that and
I think we'll be fine.
So then I talked to Neil degrasse Tyson
and I said,
how much time would we need to plan for
a satellite or an asteroid hitting us?
He goes,
at least 10 years.
Like,
what?
Ten years ago?
Ten years.
And he goes,
yeah,
I go,
so we're fucked.
He goes,
we'd
be fucked.
I'm like,
no,
this other guy lied to me.
What do you mean 10 years from when?
From when you find it to when we could
figure out a way to stop it.
Oh,
that it would take us to 10 years.
You're not so figure out towards earth.
You need 10 years gap time between
recognizing it's definitely gonna hit
earth and having the ability and the
technology to shift its direction.
Couldn't you just go and shoot a rocket
at it?
No,
Bro.
When that doesn't work,
that's what had happened in that movie.
Which one?
Deep impact or arm again?
The Will Smith one,
right?
Oh,
so armageddon was a wilson though.
So Samuel Jackson.
I know.
Which one was Samuel Jackson the
president.
Was it Morgan Freeman?
Morgan.
Morgan Freeman.
Did they give up on the me too against
him.
It seems like they let it go and I think
so.
Yeah.
They tested the waters.
Leave me alone.
Don't do any.
What do you think about this Louis ck
thing?
Seek has returned and came back arms.
Everybody's going crazy.
Crowds on again.
Did a go to Carleton against page.
Pull out his,
uh,
his instagram that again,
who has the best instagram page?
The best.
It's the best.
If you're not going there it sound
trucks and graduating Louis,
C K for his volume.
Hey,
lily trumped level.
What you did.
The comedy club.
Terrific.
Nobody doing what was happening until
you were standing right in front of
them.
Spewing out your bit.
Dariel Joe.
Well,
thank you sir.
I didn't ask at what if they wanted to
see it.
You gave them no choice but to watch you
work at.
I just went there to do some jokes are
good job.
You know.
People are like,
oh,
too soon.
I'm on stage for
you.
Shouldn't doctor about the elephant in
the room though?
Okay.
Stood up the stuff they like that just
flew in from California at Boyer byobs.
Tired but jack it up in the air.
Everybody was drafted there for is to
watch.
Be Dope.
No Way.
You're crazy.
Show
cookie.
I had a gun.
Okay.
Yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
A
so damn to kyle.
Done it on my old roommate.
Is He your real job?
And I for sure.
Did you guys live together?
New York City,
you know,
Shit.
Horrible.
One bedroom apartment had no doors.
Okay.
I was on a food time.
He was in the back.
We had no windows.
It was covered with roaches.
Wow.
No sink in the bathroom.
Look at you now,
making bread on TV.
It gets mocking the president and then
one of the best comedians.
So.
Great.
Oh,
what a mess.
What a mess.
What do you think about this?
Some people don't want him to come back.
Some people think they should be allowed
to come back and he served time off and,
and then the argument by a lot of women
is.
Yeah,
but he hasn't said anything like he had
one on anything.
Yeah.
What is,
what,
you know,
what shows that he's learned?
Anything.
Like what?
What should you have to do?
I don't know.
I mean,
Louise Very smart.
I'm sure he'll,
if he wants to keep doing it after this
reception,
he'll probably come out with some
statement or do something.
I don't know.
But the reality is,
uh,
what did he lose?
They took away networks,
took away his stuff.
Just film distributors weren't going to
put out as film.
Well,
the film,
but as a comedian
from,
by all accounts,
the film was shit.
Anybody has seen the film?
I haven't seen it.
I have a few friends that saw.
They're like,
it's just so creepy and weird,
especially in light of
what he was doing.
Yeah.
It's just like,
no,
but regardless whether it was good or
not,
I'm just saying like the industry said,
Fx said,
I'm taking this show from you ago,
said we're taking this stuff on Netflix.
We're taking this off,
but it's definitely definitely lost
money financially.
But.
And those are entities that were
companies
that punishment or is that them
exercising their desire to not work with
someone who has been accused of
something that they don't want to be
associated with?
Is that a punishment?
I don't know.
It seems to me that they're,
they're making a decision of who they
work with and who they're not work with.
It affects him negative.
Sure.
But it's not necessarily a punishment.
Well,
there's,
I don't know.
I think it would feel like a punishment.
Sure.
But my point is there's these entities
that can prevent him from making a
living as a comedian though he can walk
into a garage and if he has fans,
they're going to come see him.
He has.
He has that under his control.
Right.
Nobody can stop that,
nobody,
so he can do it.
It's up to him whether he wants to or
not.
It's up to his fans whether they show up
or not and it's up to the people that
hate what he did and I'm really against
them to not go,
well,
that's why this thing was weird,
but he just showed up with a seller
which is like his favorite place to go
and he just worked out material in the
audience.
Like Kyle was saying is just they're
trapped in there and they can't get out.
They,
they didn't have an option to say.
I don't want to see
really interesting.
All the different spins though.
All the different women spins and w one
one really bizarre spin that I saw was
this woman was saying that this is
indicative of the problem of all comedy
clubs and aggressive male audience and
women sitting there feeling threatened,
not being able to use their voice and
like use user voice.
Like what are you gonna heckle?
They were saying like you like you would
be more empowered if there were more
women,
so you could heckle is.
That's not cool,
like you're not supposed to do that at a
comedy club,
have you.
Don't like someone just don't laugh,
but
here's the thing.
It's not your job or it's not your place
to say that you don't like someone when
the other people do like it.
You know if you're right,
if you're going to get up and walk out.
Yeah,
just like you're going to see a movie
like you're an audience member,
right?
The deal is you're not there to perform.
The audience is there to just sit there
and laugh or not laugh,
but don't be rude to the other people
that are enjoying it.
So as soon as you break your
sensibilities above,
the rest of the audience will your
problem you've made.
If you decide like,
hey,
I didn't like this,
I'm going to go home and write about it,
that's totally your prerogative.
That's fine.
Get up and walk out.
Go somewhere else and talk about it on
stage yourself.
Nothing wrong with any of those things,
but this one woman's take was like women
don't feel like they have.
They can.
They have the ability to speak out about
it.
I'm like,
speak out like so you're saying like to
heckle,
Hey,
I don't want you on stage.
I know everything about you and your
story and I want you to perform in front
of me.
Even those other people that are
laughing,
right,
and that these aggressive men were
yelling,
good to see you back.
Louis aggressive men like,
well,
okay.
That's like there's a framing of this
and this is one of its becomes this male
versus female framing that sort of
represents aggressive men,
sexual men doing things to women they
don't want.
The women are sitting there in silence.
They don't want to be there and they
don't have a voice because they feel
overwhelmed and overpopulated or a
outnumbered
flurry.
Problem is those guys that Harvey and
him and Matt Lauer and people like that.
They are the poster boys for that,
so they're going to be watched very
closely and how does many of our fitting
into that
confused by this one?
By all accounts,
Matt Lauer had affairs right in the
office with girls who worked with them.
So what was inappropriate that as he was
having sex with his staff.
Right?
Right.
But he was also hitting on people that
didn't want to be hit on was in his
office.
Yeah.
That was the accusations.
It wasn't just,
he was dating them.
He was also,
you know,
making,
making weird advancements in the office.
Yeah.
That all these guys,
all these guys,
you know,
they're all very complicated.
They're all very fuzzy kind of things.
But uh,
you know,
those guys are going to be watched very
closely as you see.
Louie just goes to this little club and
does a set and it's national news and
national debate.
It's like,
it's,
it's a,
it's heady stuff.
Teddy stuff.
Yeah.
What's fascinating is that as a culture,
we're going through this great time of
change in this great time of a
introspective thinking and of observing
our behavior and discussing our behavior
and watching this,
like you have the worst case examples of
which my,
in my opinion,
is cosby.
Worst case example,
drugging people.
I mean,
there's,
there's a woman who was on television on
CNN.
She said something that freaked me out
when she said that is entirely possible
that bill cosby is the,
the most prolific serial rapist in
history.
And that's a big statement I heard that
I want.
Maybe she's right.
She's right.
Like how many,
how many people does a regular rapist
raped before they get caught?
Yeah,
just,
I mean that's the number that came out
against him.
I'm sure there's other people that you
had.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That's like the far end of the spectrum.
Right?
And then on the other end of the
spectrum,
you've got like Louis [inaudible] who's,
um,
did something definitely you wouldn't
want to happen to your wife know where
your kids,
but your friends.
I don't know the whole story.
You know,
Kurt Kurt Metzger was telling me that
one of the girls who came out against
him,
like they had been flirting like the
whole weekend and talking about sex like
the whole weekend.
And then he did that and then he had
sent the girl a text saying,
I'm really sorry that I did that.
And she said,
don't worry about it.
Look,
we were talking about sex all weekend
and then when the accusations came out,
obviously there was more accusations
that seemed to be more egregious.
She threw her hat into the mix as well.
Right.
I don't know if that's true or not
though.
The problem with a lot of these stories
is you're hearing them third,
fourth,
fifth hand,
you don't,
you know,
all you know is he said those stories
are true and that he recognized that he
did something wrong and he was going to
take time off.
So that to me is not a guy defending
himself.
That's a guy saying,
yeah,
I definitely fucked up.
I'm going to step back.
So he steps back for nine months or
whatever it was.
And people saying that's not long
enough.
You didn't do anything like you gotta.
So what,
what should someone do?
Like in one of the things that Michael,
Ian Black said on twitter before they
told his Dick off,
stuffed it in his nose,
that was a crazy thing to watch because
he's like super progressive,
very liberal.
And he was saying that,
you know,
like that me too has to offer men of
road to redemption and you know,
and a lot of these women were saying
though,
like every road to redemption begins
with.
I'm sorry,
which is a very valid point,
very valid point.
Like you should,
you should have to say,
I'm sorry,
you know,
and I think he's said,
I'm sorry,
but I don't know what he said to the
women.
I don't know what he said.
I don't mean you had to one public
statement,
did he say I'm sorry.
And that what public statement,
that times article is kind of like a
availed.
I'm sorry,
I think,
I don't know that it's,
I don't know,
you know,
I hesitate to comment on any of it
because it's like his mess and like if
anyone that comments on it or it comes
near it or like the,
the owner of the comedy cellar,
everyone's got to deal with the
aftermath,
the aftermath of what this guy did.
It's like,
why am I as the owner of the seller,
it's like,
why is he have to get brought into
Louise Behavior?
I saw at least a half a dozen articles
written about what a piece of Shit
Michael Che was for saying that he,
Louis deserves the opportunity to make a
living.
Right.
Going after Michael Che and his is
useless,
like,
you know,
but look,
it's there.
They're allowed their opinion that
Michael Che's opinions useless.
I mean,
this is one of the beautiful things
about free expression
now complete.
That's what,
that's what I'm,
that's where it's kind of the most
interesting for me.
And I don't mean that I take pleasure in
any of this because it's horrible for
everyone involved.
But uh,
it's interesting.
Like I said,
there's companies that probably won't go
back into business with him,
but as a comedian,
you know,
he could put a show up in the park,
he could put a show up anywhere he
wants.
It's really up to him and people can
protest it.
They can not show up.
They can buy tickets by the thousands.
It's going to be interesting to see when
he takes that part of his earning and
that part of his life in his own hands,
you really can't stop him.
Yeah,
I'm in that way.
It's like it's how you frame it,
so I don't think,
I don't think louise a bad guy at all.
I think what Louis is a pervert and I
think he's,
you know,
he's into,
I think part of it is like being naughty
and doing something that's forbidden and
you know,
in getting away with it and having these
girls like him for being a comedian and
then doing that to them.
I mean this is just my speculation.
There's a lot of weirdness to it,
but I don't think that he's like,
I'm an angry person and I don't think
he's trying to be hurtful.
I don't think any of that was.
I think it was just terrible judgment.
Everything.
I mean you could say a lot about it.
That's fucked up,
but it's like what it is,
is not.
He's not like,
he's not trying to hurt people.
I think he's just fucking weird.
You mean let's think about what it is
he's asking.
Can I jerk off in front of you?
Like it's the whole.
I mean,
it's like,
yeah,
when it comes to that kind of creepy
shit is like the most considerate way to
approach it.
[inaudible] can I jerk off in front of
you?
And he's like literally asking adorable,
so fucked up.
I mean,
it is a mess.
I'm not diminishing the effect that it
would have on a woman who respects them
and wants,
you know,
she just thinks that he's our friend and
next thing you know,
he's got his dick out.
Like I get it.
I'm not saying that's not what I'm
saying.
It's a weird thing because you don't
want.
Those women were obviously very hurt and
there's degrees of like,
oh,
they see texted this or they said that
to go out and do that to somebody in a
powerful position and come out and say
it and know that you're going to get
hate from the world.
They were,
they were in a place that they were hurt
enough that they felt that they had to
say something and do something.
Sure.
And you just want like on this personal
level,
you want them to be okay.
Right?
You want everybody to be okay.
You want them to be okay and feel like
they had justice and for coming out,
being brave enough to come out and say
something.
But you also want to protect people from
that happening again,
but.
Right,
right.
The
only way,
one of the only ways,
just like you got to kind of,
you know this and there was,
there was a,
there's definitely a feeling,
you know,
the,
the comedy world is separate and we're
kind of like,
you know,
it's a crazy environment and nightclub
kind of a thing.
And what you heard when these ones,
these women came out was now this is
kind of inappropriate that girls,
women can,
can't come into a club and just feel
okay.
Like they have to field all this stuff
and guys hitting on them all the time.
Like it kind of made you look at the
scene and be like alright maybe this
scene could be cleaned up a little bit
as well.
It's like what I was saying about really
a worse version of working out at a gay
gym.
So if you go to a gay gym and you see
men Leer at you get that feeling that
these guys want to have sex with you and
you definitely don't want to have sex
with them.
That is how women feel all the time.
Yeah.
And you're coming to the comedy store or
wherever and you're trying to just start
out as a comic and that's such a big
thing already.
And then you throw a whole nother level
layer on it that everyone's hitting on
you from the doorman to the headliner.
That's gotta be a big thing and it's
like.
So I think that those women should feel
good,
that it.
It definitely made an impact.
They should know that they've been heard
and that they,
they,
they shined a light on something that
even people that were in it,
men that were in it were unaware of.
Yeah,
they were definitely heard.
It's very difficult for people to
consider really objectively consider
other people's perspectives.
Like really,
people consider it in a convenient way.
Like,
you know,
like they know what they can get away
with what they do.
They really consider how the other
person feels and thinks and you know,
and that's on both sides.
It's hard.
There's inconsiderate women is
inconsiderate men and you know,
we,
we both do it to each other and then
people develop bad traits and bad
associations with the opposite sex and
it's a very common thing that people do.
But I think situations where the
discussion is so emotionally charged
like this,
it's good for us.
It's good for us.
It allows the,
this,
this public discourse.
It allows this public discussion of it.
Yeah.
And,
and there hasn't been like,
you know,
people that have gotten hurt by that
have come out and said it,
like in our scene where they're like
nice people and they've been attacked.
It was very few,
but it was like,
hey,
there's some big important people in
this scene and they're acting in
appropriately and then,
you know,
you're right.
I think it's good.
It's definitely woken up and moved it
further.
Right.
I have a funny daughter.
I know you have a funny daughter who
knows if they see our life and want to
go pursue it.
You want them to be able to go to a club
and not have to deal with a whole
nother.
It's enough when you're starting out to
get five minutes of good material and to
get the audience to like you and get the
respect of your peers.
Then you got to have about someone
following you in the,
in the parking lot.
I have a friend of mine who's a comic
and she got hit on by.
This other guy was a comic who shall
remain nameless.
And uh,
she showed me some of the texts that he
sent her and I was like,
Holy Shit.
All right.
And one of them was like,
I'm the only one that can make you calm
or something fucking crazy.
I'm Jeez.
Yeah.
It's,
hey bro.
Yeah.
But those.
So then it comes down to,
okay,
so these women were heard.
Obviously it's created a movement,
you know,
but then it becomes on the other side it
becomes about.
But did this man's,
was he punished enough and do we have
control over whether or not he's allowed
to come back to the audience?
Like for a woman,
like the,
the thing about a guy being angry with
you,
it carries that threat of physical
danger.
You know,
that's a different thing.
I know.
I was thinking I was on a hike the other
day and I was thinking about that fine
line at the end of the night in a bar.
Those meat head guys were trying to like
hit on girls and when it doesn't work
they decide they're just going to fight
instead.
Couldn't lesbian know that they're going
to fight.
Guys,
that's a fine line between,
you know what I mean?
They're both almost violent acts.
It's like aggressively hitting on women
and being like,
it's not going to happen.
Well screw it.
I don't like the way that has been
looking at.
I think it's just frustration,
but you know it's traded but it.
But for looking at a male doing that,
like it isn't aggressive.
This is an aggressive animal here and a
one minute he could've been.
I could've said yes and brought him home
with me when I said no.
And now he's punching that guy in the
parking lot though I don't want really a
common narrative whenever don't get
laid.
They try to hit on girls and they just
beat the shit out of each other.
Yeah.
It seems like it happens.
Oh,
this fucking sucks.
It seems like it happens all the time.
Oh,
there's such in my body and you know,
when you're walking down the in the.
Even in the village you're walking down
the street and there's just like an
angry frat group of guys just like
raging drunk,
you know,
they were trying to get laid at minutes
earlier.
Yeah.
Male anchors my point.
My point being that there's men are
formidable creatures and they're big and
they're hairy and there's why the 7
billion people,
because men are gross and they shoot
each other.
Everybody's shooting loads into people.
Especially at your weightlifting gym.
I had a friend,
a gay friend in,
in New York and that,
what was the name of that gym there?
David Barton or something like that.
What?
David Barton.
It's some kind of health club in New
York.
And it was,
it was,
uh,
it was mostly gay men.
And my friend said,
he said,
no,
you don't understand.
It's really,
I mean it's to the point where when
you're working out on the machine,
there are pin lights that come right
down on your bicep.
Like there,
the lighting is made to make you look
sexy or while you're working out,
it was the greatest team of all time.
They have like specific
kind of lighting to Ross to a true.
Yeah,
we can back.
It was on a curling machine right now.
There'd be a light that came from the
ceiling like that hits where your biceps
to make the shadows,
make the exit peaks look bigger.
Yeah.
So it's about sex.
You're working out.
Well,
if you go to a regular gym,
you see people hitting on each other all
the time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Is that it?
Even Barton Gym
one in Chelsea
doesn't look sexy.
Bold was dumbbells.
What is that?
It looks like a bar.
Oh,
those are machines,
those cardio machines.
Oh,
weird.
Sex is a weird thing.
It is for sure.
Well,
it's even weirder when it's packaged
with advertising and sleekness and music
and,
and then you see it in real life and
people are tech sells baby and then on
their social media and everyone's
sticking their ass out and you know,
it's like there's so much going on.
Yeah,
there's so much.
We're so overstimulated with sexual
imagery.
Do you feel like you'll be grateful and
you're old and your sex drive is gone?
No,
it'd be almost dead.
Then I'll be like,
sad.
What do you hate?
Sex?
No,
it's not about sex being bad.
It's about being an asshole and it's
also about the shit roll.
The dice that you get.
If you're physically unattractive,
what's difficult to get someone who's
attracted to you that's hard to.
That is hard.
That is inescapable reality of some
people's bodies.
Some people were just,
they have bad genetics and then it must
be insanely frustrating.
It's got to be frustrated,
but then you got to just find someone
else.
It's funny looking.
Then you don't want them
to hit on you the way she hit on a
Michael Douglas movie.
Oh,
come on,
champion.
This disclosure movies,
do you know that people are mad that
someone's playing the elephant man,
but that they're enabled bodied person?
This is the most recent pc uproar that
they hired and able bodied actor to play
the elephant man.
Well,
how many elephant men are in the actor's
guild?
It's just exhausting.
It's exhausting keeping up with
everything.
Every.
Everything is outrageous.
Everything.
Yeah.
Well,
this is the time.
Like you said,
like we're getting outraged and
discussions and then it'll kind of come
back to a normal stranger things and
elephant man remake criticized by
disability charity,
but you know what this is?
Do you know you need a good actor?
Yeah,
there's.
You just can't be happy.
And by the way,
here's the thing.
No disrespect to the disability charity,
but a lot of these disability charities
criticized this just so that they can
highlight their charity and it's very
good for the charity if they criticize
things because it makes people aware of
it,
it becomes a big public story and then
they get donations.
It's not bad for them to consider the
source.
I mean,
they're probably just artists trying to
make the film and who knows if they're
good people,
then you know that they're going to
respect it.
No need disability person in their
person with disability to play a person
with disability period.
You piece of shit.
But isn't that what?
Shut the fuck up and let people have
disability speak.
But I thought acting was pretending.
How about something that you're not
first people of color speak then women
of color,
then women,
then gay,
lesbian,
straight trans,
bisexual,
asexual,
intersexual venue.
You fucking white male bread making
piece of shit.
I just make bread.
Leave me out of all of your crazy sex.
Condoms.
I don't know what's going on with all
you guys.
Do you want to be an ally or not?
You son of a bitch.
A look.
I'm just trying to show you the best
cupcakes in New York.
Oh,
what are you doing in la?
You going to film in La?
Yeah,
we did vetoes.
Did vetoes pizza.
Where did you go?
Was Vetoes Pizza Pizza,
right by Largo.
Between Largo and um,
a good comedy store.
So good.
Really?
This guy is a good pizza place in the
best pizza in La.
I'm telling you how good is.
He came from New Jersey.
His name is Vito.
He's sourdough startups in the water.
No,
he says it's not about the water.
That's a farce.
He goes,
you just have to know what you're doing.
He does have good ingredients.
His crest is impeccable because he knows
how to make the dough.
Wally.
Yeah,
this guy's legit.
He's lying about it.
Now.
Vetoes the real deal.
Females got trucks of water in his
backyard.
He's not telling nobody
can veto the fucking meet Bob.
Oh,
that looks so good.
So good.
If I was going to go off my diet,
I would be not.
Meet saw.
So good.
Getting it looks very good as well.
Everything.
This guy makes this amazing.
Literally smelled like my grandmother's
house.
Holy Veto.
You motherfucker in Quito.
Say solvay.
Fucking donuts.
A veto.
Come on Joe,
and you're off it and we're at the
store.
We'll go to vetoes.
It's literally down the street.
I'm on it right now.
For how long?
Strip?
Like I go on and off Iguana for a few
months,
I'll go off.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean occasionally I'll have a cheat
day and so I'll,
I'll,
it'll knock me out of Ketosis for a few
hours and knocked me back just a few
hours.
Yeah.
But right now I'm in a,
you would call it mild ketosis.
If you look at my pis strip,
I put it up on my instagram is a chart.
It shows you like the darkest to the
lightest.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm in like a mid.
Several been on it for five days,
six days.
How do you feel?
I've always feel good.
I get used to doing it.
I'm used to,
it seems to weird.
Seems like I'm not on that spectrum at
all because it dried out a little bit
before I put it up to what happens if
you eat a slice of vetoes,
it'll knock me down to that negative was
nothing back.
I would call that one slice.
Yeah,
I would call it.
I'm somewhere in the range of moderate,
moderate Ketosis,
moderate,
but again,
I pissed on him.
Then I let this trip sit for a little
bit and it dried and it looks a little
weird.
Disgusting.
Anyway,
what it does for me though,
it's very good for my appetite and
cognitive benefits like my mind feels
clear when you put them on it.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
I think there's a certain amount of fog
that comes with carbohydrate consumption
too much.
Yeah.
Well,
carbohydrate consumption in general and
when you,
when you eat carbohydrates post
carbohydrate consumption is a lack of
mental clarity,
like a down turn of the way your brain
functions,
what I call that sleep nap.
Time nap,
eat sweet,
sweet nap time,
nap time.
When you and I contrast in many ways my
friend,
I try and dial it in.
Yeah.
I don't eat this stuff all the time,
but you know.
Yeah.
But he.
Look,
you love it.
I do love nothing wrong with it.
I love the celebration of life and one
of my favorite dishes on planet earth is
linguine with clams.
When I want to go off,
like when I was in Italy,
I was in Italy a couple of weeks ago.
Oh yeah.
Where'd you go to everyday?
Ravello Ravello where's the Amalfi
coast?
Went to copper and we took a boat to
copper and we ate there and fucking
phenomenal food.
The food was outrageous.
So fresh clams with the sardines man
filets starting filets in olive oil.
So the best.
So.
Oh my God.
Oh,
good clams.
The clamp.
Everything was so fresh.
But it was interesting.
They were um,
a Valentine Thomas who is a professional
pr spear.
Fisher person.
She was on the other day and she was
saying that the oceans in that area are
completely overfished.
Really?
Yeah.
That's like,
it's almost impossible for a regular
person to go there and catch a fish
that's Texas overfished everything.
It's a bummer being alive now.
It's such a bummer that every,
everywhere you go,
it's always the end of whatever.
It's the end of the coral reef.
It's the end of these animals running
through the woods at the end of such a
bummer.
You know,
like even like I tried to show my kids
like nice nature videos,
like I used to watch with my dad and
everyone at the end is like,
but this is going away,
and I was just like,
ugh.
It sucks.
Some of it is going away.
Yeah,
most of it.
I mean it's how you look at it.
It's like we're definitely in an
unsustainable path,
right?
In terms of just what we're doing
agriculturally.
If you,
if you talk to farmers and you
appreciate this,
what they do with large scale
agriculture,
you're not supposed to grow food in the
same plot of land for fucking 50 years.
Corn and just constantly soy,
throwing minerals on the ground and
constantly growing and then you get
these minerally deficient plants,
you know,
they're just not the same and it's just
not.
It's not good for you.
That's the only thing is good for is
like deer because deer
can combine,
eat all your corn when they want.
You get a high population of deer in the
area,
but you're not supposed to feed cattle
corn either.
No.
It depends also like wildlife is
supposed to exist in like wildlife
habitat,
which is like forests and grasslands and
meadows and sun fed.
Fed plants.
Yeah.
They're supposed to be wandering around
eating all these things.
They're not supposed to be existing in
these massive thousand Acre Cornfield,
so great.
It's just weird.
It's like white tailed deer.
To a certain extent.
This country have become like farm
animals there go weird farm animal
that's not in a fence,
right?
They're just always around farms.
Just eating farm food.
Yeah.
Like my friend Doug had this interesting
thought about that.
He was like,
these are.
He goes to my cows are eating grass
because he has a farm barn.
The cows are eating.
Those cows are natural,
right?
They're organic.
They're eating grass.
My dear are eating gmo corn who also the
deer that are on my property.
That desert wild.
The wild animals are not organic.
That's weird.
It's so crazy because you're eating
something that's totally unnatural for
them to eat,
which is gmo corn.
Corn is everywhere and it's gmo corn
because he's growing this corn.
That side.
Yeah.
It's like Monsanto corn,
so he's growing this roundup fucking
sprayed corn.
She had these deer eating
deer,
but yet the cows that are in captivity
are grazing naturally grass and they're
a hundred percent organic.
She's.
It's weird,
weird,
weird.
I was reading that,
that the whole fertilizer thing that we
weren't able to get nitrogen out of the
air until this one scientist did it.
Fritz Haber,
Fritz Haber.
Yeah.
Those.
The same guy who created Zyklon Nazi,
right?
No,
no.
He was a Jew.
It was a Jew is a Jew in Germany and he
was there in Germany.
Well,
in World War One,
he was the guy who created the gas that
they use to spray on the allies and he
actually,
at the same time,
he created the hopper method for
extracting nitrogen from the atmosphere,
which led to,
they think that the nitrogen and
people's.
There's a great radio lab podcast on it.
Um,
I think it's called the bad show and it
shows how sometimes good people also do
horrible things.
And Fritz harbor was one of the ones
that they,
they highlighted.
But when he was,
when they were going to give him the
Nobel prize for creating the harbor
method for extracting nitrogen from the
atmosphere,
and the air around us is 80 percent
nitrogen,
but you couldn't get it out right.
You couldn't get it out.
He figured out how to get.
Like when we breed,
we think we breathing in oxygen mostly.
No,
it's mostly nitrogen and then some
oxygen and he figured out how to get it
out and turn it into fertilizer and use
it in on soil and really increased
radically the amount of food that people
are able to grow.
He also at the same time figured out how
to spray gas on on the troops,
so they wanted him for crimes against
humanity.
They wanted him for war crime at the
same time.
They were going to give him the Nobel
prize.
Oh my God,
fucking car.
And then they used his gas for the
concentration on his family.
Check this out and his extended family
because he created [inaudible] on gas.
But he puts in Zyklon A.
There's a smell that they attached to it
so that you were aware of when the gas
was present,
so like if you were working with it,
if there was a leak,
it was a very obvious smell.
The Nazis took cycle on a and remove
that smell and turned to design clumpy,
which they used to spray the.
The people in the concentration camp.
Jews and his family got caught.
Some of his extended family was killed
with the very gas that he created.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And then he died.
He was exiled from Germany.
The whole thing was horrible.
His.
He was a Jew and so he tried to stand up
for Jews as scientists and as people.
And it was like slowly getting pushed
out of the Nazis were taking control.
Oh my God.
And then he wanted to believe in the
country and he attack.
He had,
he had,
he had terrible health.
Right.
And he died like,
I think he was going to Switzerland for
treatment and he wound up dying.
She's little,
his wife killed herself.
Wife shot himself,
shot herself in the chest in a,
in,
in front of.
Well,
it was him and his son and he left his
13 year old son with his dead wife and
then went back to war.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
She did it because.
Because he was killing people with gas.
Is Gas was used.
She was.
She was apparently gravely.
She was a scientist as well.
Oh my.
She was gravely upset at the direction
that his science had taken that he was.
He was involved in this new thing.
I mean,
imagine you're the architect of this new
method of killing mass.
Extermination.
But then here's the.
Here's the other problem with that.
That's a crazy story.
It's crazy,
but what does.
What does that mean?
Like he's too good at killing people.
Oh,
we don't believe in killing people by
having them choked to death on the fluid
in their lungs is built up because of
poison.
We would rather you take a bullet to the
Dick,
like
what the fuck you were in war cannons
and people.
They have these gigantic 50 millimeter
guns blowing people to smithereens and
that's okay,
but the gas is not okay.
Like we have rules where we're supposed
to kill,
kill the right way.
What the fuck?
We're dropping nuclear bombs on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Nuclear bombs that are completely
indiscriminate.
Wipe out entire cities.
Killed hundreds of thousands of people
in one blast.
That's okay,
but that's clean.
That gas,
that gas is dirty.
You're an asshole to use the gas bro.
Terrible stories.
We're.
It's a very terrible store.
It's weird store.
So then he created,
so they took that and that's where
fertilizer came from.
You know where he went wrong.
He was trying to fund the war effort by
extracting gold from the ocean who is
convinced that just like his hobby or
method of extracting nitrogen from the
air,
he was going to be able to because the
ocean has gold in.
It was very small amounts of gold,
but he felt like if you could get it all
together,
it would be a large amount and he could
extract that gold from the ocean and
then use it to fund the war effort.
Sounds like you and I have a treasure
to do once the bread shows,
but gold show,
tom and joe,
scuba gear on bags.
Harbor Gold process is unique for
several reasons.
It effectively is capable of yielding
extraction efficiencies with complex
oars in the high 90 percent range with
gold purity in the 99 percent range.
Preprocessing prior to process.
We carefully analyze the or for the
content of other minerals and or
constituents.
So is this,
is this something that they actually
use?
See,
maybe they use it now.
They use it for other things that didn't
go to the society and I eliminated
Sinai.
He was a genius,
but I don't.
The gold thing didn't pan out.
Wink,
wink,
nudge,
no pun intended.
Get it.
Pan for gold.
It didn't work,
but he apparently worked on that for
years and years and it just never came
to fruition.
Well that was his failure,
but as big success,
he felt like he was going to recreate
the nitrogen method with the gold
method.
Like figure it out another way to just
be a hero for Germany.
Amazing.
An amazing story.
Crazy.
What's so now we're left with corn being
fed to cows,
has corn in
it is awful.
But here's the thing is I read about
that stuff and uh,
you know,
you read about this,
it's such an unnatural thing that we're
doing to the cattle to feed them this
corn and dualism.
But are we at a point where there's just
so many people on the planet that this
is the only way you can do it?
Or is there other ways to do it?
Maybe like a,
I'm gonna read you.
Some people are always complaining about
the methane gas that's produced by cows
and that was one of the big arguments
that people would say,
well one of the reasons why people
should not eat cows is because if you do
eat cows,
like say if you're on like that
carnivore diet and you're.
All you eat is cows.
It has a massive negative contribution
to the environment.
But Sean Baker sent me this scientific
overview and it says in the
environmental side of the United States,
the entirety of all plants and animal
agriculture contributes to nine percent
of the total unit.
US greenhouse gas emissions,
animal agriculture makes up about four
percent and cattle,
uh,
specifically about one point nine
percent based on the latest EPA data.
If every single person in the United
States gives up eating meat and went
vegan
end,
every single animal were to magically
disappear.
The overall worldwide effect on
greenhouse gas emissions would be about
less than one percent difference.
But as I spoke with a professor,
frank,
I say this guy's name mid low her from a
UC Davis,
uh,
one of the world's leading authorities
on greenhouse gases and animal
agriculture.
And said,
putting the blame on meat is a
disservice.
And it distracts from the real issue of
our tremendous fossil fuel utilization.
Interesting.
But there's a lot that goes.
It's not just the gas that's coming off
of,
right?
It's where this is the methane,
the question,
right?
You know,
the,
the real concern that keeps coming up.
Like I had this lady and she's on this
carnivore diet,
which it seems to me that she's got.
She had some matches,
massive autoimmune issues like had her
hip replaced and she was 17 and her
ankle replaced like massive arthritis
issues and she's on this diet of all
meat and several other people on this
diet as well.
They're calling it the carnivore diet
and experiencing,
at least for the short term,
they're experiencing these tremendous
benefits.
So the critics are saying you are
contributing to greenhouse gases and
methane.
You're ruining the environment by eating
beef.
And he's saying,
well,
not really.
The the,
the,
the amount is very small in comparison
to all the other issues.
It's less than one percent of the
greenhouse gases,
but then they also hear that on that
argument that it's really oil that is
being used,
right?
It's,
it's still a,
a carbon based thing to try to transport
it,
to support the food from the farming all
the way through the transporting to
getting rid of the waste to doing all of
it that there's for now,
but Tesla's making semis,
Tesla's,
they're constructing these gigantic.
Super Cool.
Look and fucking Tron,
semis,
they're going to operate entirely on
batteries and once that happens you have
automated battery controlled trucks.
Then I think the real problem is going
to be people out of jobs.
That's going to be a giant crisis.
Even robots.
Yeah.
Once,
especially for drivers apparently for
men in particular,
some massive number in the millions of
people in this country rely on driving
for a living.
Like that's a big part of their job,
their drivers.
Um,
it's a,
it's a giant industry.
Well,
they say that's happening now across all
industries that are trying to figure
out.
Yeah,
the automation is putting so many people
out of work.
Yeah.
I'm going to talk to Bernie Sanders
about that.
You who?
Yeah,
no way.
Yeah.
Me and Bernie been emailing each other.
Really burning.
That'd be a great one.
John.
Joe,
Joe.
I'd like to talk to that guy.
I also want to talk to other people that
are proponents of universal basic income
and Ilan has said that he thinks that
this is gonna be a real factor in the
future.
Universal basic income.
So this is a truck that we're looking
at right now in a video and what it
looks like.
A rolling.
Is anyone in that apple store from
yesterday in Iowa?
They showed it off.
That's crazy.
Twenty six cameras on board.
That's so dope.
Where's the batteries?
Is that on the bottom?
Is the bottom of the batteries?
Is that driving itself?
I don't know.
It was there.
Someone driving that know the trailer is
all batteries
strapped packages.
Thing is the price.
The price is supposed to be around
$200,000 for one of those.
Dude,
this is what we do.
We buy one of those bitches and we turn
it into a roving podcast studio.
Drive us across the country.
That would be the coolest.
We talk shit in the back.
Wait,
it's driving on its own or there is a
human driving it.
That one had a human driving it.
I.
I don't believe these are in production
yet.
So it's chasing a prototype.
That dork chasing,
trying to get himself
and he's running.
He's like,
oh,
I can run to.
That is the coolest.
I had a gig up in.
I'm a last minute gig in Yosemite.
It was a casino up there,
uh,
to open for smokey Robinson.
Well,
what was that like?
It was the coolest you meet him.
Uh,
I did meet him.
I met him once before.
It was actually a cool story about,
about meeting him.
But uh,
I was going to take the tesla up and ran
out.
I was like,
yeah.
Like I was trying to plot,
like,
do,
will I be able to do it?
Get rid of that piece of no problem,
no problem.
Fuck,
they're everywhere now.
Supercharger near Fresno.
Just playing out eight hours in advance.
You could pull off for eight hours and
let you shit charge up factors in that.
You're only going to be 20 minutes of
charge or,
or 30 minutes of chart here.
I'm telling you,
I'm out of here.
You do stop in for 20 minutes at a time.
Yeah.
Well if you stop and pee and get a
coffee and read a book,
take a shit,
go over your twitter feed cars out there
charging.
It was great.
The goddamn car,
like a man who was so great.
Mustang something with some rumble too.
It was such a nice drive.
Don't you have a midlife crisis or
something?
Going through the.
The prairie of Yosemite.
What if your bread sunrise bread showed
takes off?
Get yourself a corvette.
I laugh and you never drive a corvette
if you had to drive.
It's so funny.
That's such a
life dream Dude.
Tony got a corvette.
Did he really?
Yeah.
He calls himself.
He says he has corvette confidence.
When I texted him,
I texted him.
Hashtag corvette confidence.
When you drive a car,
fun like,
dude,
I drive it to work.
It's a game changer.
I'm driving to the comedy store.
I get fired up.
Fast.
Rumbled healed.
Especially to the ice house because it's
further away.
I get that.
There is some.
I have a vw bug that's just shut your
mouth.
Don't ever new telling you.
Just having a fucking corvette.
You sort of just having the engine and
you're shifting and the smell of gas.
It does something to you for sure.
I love new bugs.
I'm just kidding.
They're very mechanical,
but do you have an old one?
60 seven.
Oh,
those are the real ones.
That's beautiful.
Little sewing machine.
The bag.
It's fun.
They're so light too.
Yeah.
You know what they've done with those?
They've taken those old vw bug and put
an old porsche engine in the back.
Now there's a lot of people doing that
with the buses too.
Yeah,
so they'd put like 170 horsepower old
porsche engine,
which doesn't seem like a lot.
One hundred 70 horsepower.
It's not a lot,
but the car weighs nothing.
Yeah,
more than that.
Yeah.
With the gas tank in the front of your
car and you get those little tiny skinny
tires on it.
Tuesday,
stand out all over the place.
I think the beauty of it is that you
have the original engine and you just
kind of puttering along,
but everyone gets annoyed.
It's like a,
like a slow clown car.
People cut you off just to get around.
You just don't even want to look at you
and not in this day and age.
I mean you think about how fast teslas
are.
Oh my God.
Those things are unbelievably fast.
It's another
station.
It's.
It's definitely satisfying.
It's not that gas law,
but there's a.
This is telling you the sunrise was
coming up and I'm just silent.
No other cars around.
Just going through this prairie
going to beach,
smokey Robinson.
Let me stop for an hour and a half to
get some electricity.
Oh,
I can drive for two hours now.
Pull over.
How much time do you have to plan out
just for charging extra five hours.
I spent a good day at trying to figure
out my ribs.
No,
but here's the rock star move.
Uh,
I had met smokey once before in New
York.
We did a charity for kids in the arts,
kid rock,
kids rock or something,
a kids who?
Rutgers School of rock,
something like that.
Anyway,
I'd met him before,
so I was excited to take the GIG and I
figured I'll meet smokey Robinson.
It's an outdoor arena,
you know,
it's an outdoor event.
And uh,
they just used me to burn time while the
sun went down and then he could come out
at nighttime.
And uh,
so I'm sitting there with a guy that I'm
just talking to and smoky comes out of
our dressing rooms or trailers because
it's outside and this gravel driveway
and stuff and smoke.
He comes out,
he's like 78 now.
He's in all red,
red jumpsuit,
red,
cool jacket,
red leather boots.
And he comes out and I'm like,
all right,
I'll get to say hi to smokey suv door
opens.
He goes right into the SUV and he drives
literally 20 feet so.
And drops them off at the stage so he
could go right up onto the stage.
He didn't even want to get his.
He didn't want to get his boots dirty on
the gravel walkway.
Yeah.
So they.
So they literally put them in this suv.
I'm telling you from here to the end of
your studio.
They just dropped him off and he went
right up on stage.
And like that,
that smokey that is okay.
That is a kick ass rockstar move.
That's,
that's.
If you don't want to keep your,
you know,
you won't want to get your boots dirty.
It's good move.
Yeah.
Comedians don't think that way.
No.
I'm walking to my dress shoes across the
thing.
Just get them all dirty and fucked up.
I feel like one of the people that way.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
We're not rockstars rockstars.
A different thing,
man.
Totally.
Especially that.
That kind of smooth skin has been a rock
star for a long time forever.
My parents were listening to them when
they were teenagers,
you know?
I mean,
that's a long time that he's been still
as the voice still.
Is this cool moves?
Is he healthy?
You can move.
Well,
totally.
Wow.
She's got this really cool.
Like does he exercise?
Did you talk to him?
I didn't know.
How would I talk to someone that's that
old that's been around for that long.
See what the Jagger.
Apparently it's just an exercise
fanatic.
Yeah,
he's.
That's what I heard you exercise twice a
day.
Yeah.
And realize was like this.
The only way,
the only way you can keep this up,
amazing.
Just,
I mean he's in his seventies.
The only way his body's going to
maintain health because he's got to
consistently exercise so funny that he's
next to Keith.
The total opposite way to go.
The miracles.
Look at them smoking.
Wow.
Nineteen 65.
Sixty five.
That picture's already a star.
That's amazing.
God,
what does he look like today,
but very similar.
Smokey Robinson in 2018.
Is that him?
Well,
that's Tony Bennett and lady Gaga,
so that's probably serious.
Yeah.
Let's go to that picture.
Make that picture bigger.
It looks pretty.
God damn good.
What's happening?
Good.
Lady Gaga.
Look Smoking.
Yeah.
She looks like she looks like she's
going to forget how hot she is.
She's in a star is born.
Somebody tell me she me.
She wasn't hot and like picture out of
your mind.
You tell them you wouldn't smash.
You ever see those videos of her when
she was like an Nyu or something like
doing?
Just starting out.
She's super talented.
Totally.
In a weird way,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
very her own way,
you know?
Yeah.
She's amazing.
A harmful.
Smokey,
smokey.
Yeah.
We don't have any comics that are that
old right now that are like,
like once.
Yeah,
once George Carlin died.
Carla was like our last great touring
stand up.
That was of that age from the sixties.
Yeah.
No one else is like that.
That's still around.
No.
Joan rivers gone.
Rickles gun though.
Oh,
you know who is so um,
Bob Newhart.
Bob newhart still doing gigs.
Did you take a long time off and start
doing them again or something now?
We just would always kinda quietly do
it.
Really?
No kidding.
You've seen him?
I've never seen him.
Now you actually,
he was on Conan the other night and I
was going to try and get tickets to see
him in the palm desert.
Burl and I were planning on going to see
cosby before the scandal broke.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We,
you know,
because we had,
we were talking to him one night at the
store and we'd always heard like how
good he is.
Got to go see him.
You got to go see.
I'm like,
Chris Rock had said,
dude,
he fucking killed.
He killed for two hours.
He went on stage with no opening act.
He just walks out there and he starts
talking and she starts crushing and he
goes,
I was blown away and Chris Rock was
saying this.
He goes,
well,
I went
to see him.
I was like,
God damn man,
I'm an amateur.
And I was like,
wow.
And it was like,
oh,
we should go.
So burt and I were planning and
something came out we had to cancel.
And then right after that,
something fucking,
something big came up
down there.
We're like,
Oh God,
that's terrible.
I saw som though.
Bill went and song.
I saw him.
Uh,
my wife was pregnant with our first baby
and we had,
I was doing Conan and then I was going
to have two weeks off before the baby
was born.
That was gonna be the last Gig I did.
We're going to take two weeks off and
just hang out.
Before this new baby came,
we were living in New York and we went
to see cosby.
Seinfeld took us to see cosby at
Carnegie Hall.
Wow.
And we laughed for two hours.
It was a masterclass that he was so
good,
so easy,
and we just laughed forever and uh,
went home and her water broke.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
We always felt like that.
All that laughing kind of made her water
break,
but it was a,
it was definitely impressive.
Impressive.
You know,
it was impressive about it.
He would tell these stories and build
the,
build it without laughs.
There would be like very few labs for
like 10 minutes as he's telling the
story.
And you didn't realize even as a comic
that he was building this tension.
So when the laugh did come,
it was bigger than any laugh you've ever
heard.
I mean he would just,
it was the building of it.
He's the confidence to not feel like he
had to go from laugh to laugh,
to laugh every 30 seconds.
He would just let it build
bill and then it would ba boom.
It would explode.
I wonder if there's recordings of him
later in life,
like before the scandal broke,
like when he was in his seventies
before.
Because I think now it would be
impossible.
Like if you go to see him,
don't.
I know he's not performing now,
but if you was,
it would be impossible.
I wouldn't want to go.
It's like so gross and so tainted and so
it's a shame.
It's like you would have crazy.
You'd have to watch him almost like a
scientist and observe him before.
I wonder if it would think about it too.
Like now if you watch,
even if you want you to recording,
you'd be watching it thinking I wonder
if he right now in the back of his mind,
he's like,
Holy Shit,
I'm a rapist and they don't know.
I know.
I haven't looked at anything that he's
done since then.
I mean that was such a.
He was trying to make a public relations
come back.
Last year he did a,
if you find a find a video of bill cosby
holding court in a barbershop in Philly.
He was at a barbershop and Philly and
they were talking about jazz musicians
and like he was like giving them,
giving them trivia questions.
He's barbershop,
jazz musicians,
and I was reading the comments and the
comments are like,
we love you,
bill,
believe you bill.
You know those accusers are assholes,
like,
look at this.
Give me some volume
raises on base,
on base making and I'm making up these
because you don't have your glass.
He told me that I'll take a two hour
shot.
He
told me,
he said,
this doctor got me.
I said,
Dr. I take my shower.
I'm one of those people that wipe the
shower now.
I don't want the water running on the
towel.
I don't want them to be able to do.
I want to be clean and dry when I get
out of that.
Obviously maybe with me properly,
but obviously you live alone
so you have to clean up as my father
would say,
behind your own mess.
Even when I was married,
I did the same thing.
Everybody in the house after a certain
age,
he looks really old independently.
Take care of
unanimous when they left,
but they was independently.
They can stand on.
It's weird to watch him because this
life as well.
He's wearing that hello friend.
He kept,
he would wear that on stage,
he would wear sweaters that say hello
friend.
He started saying that clothes dressing
up on stage was a crutch,
so sometimes he would come out with just
like his birkenstocks and just take them
off.
He just be in his socks.
He thought that being dressed up was
like putting on too much of a show that
you should rely purely on the spoken
word of it.
Well,
I mean I don't buy that.
I certainly,
I certainly don't.
I don't buy you telling other people how
they should do it.
Anything.
I mean there's,
there's a bunch of ways to do it.
Well,
of course he wants to be comfortable on
stage.
Where a hello friends?
Sweatshirt.
Well he's fine,
but he was big at telling people how
they're supposed to live.
Right?
I mean,
well that was going up there.
That's so ironic about it because Eddie
Murphy,
first of all would go on stage with
fucking leather jumpsuits on like bright
red jumpsuits unzipped down to the
naval.
Yeah.
And then cosby would attack him because
he dropped that bombs split me.
But meanwhile it's so gross.
So Gross,
so gross.
Well hypocrites,
man,
I know.
Strange like that kind of a hypocrite,
like telling you how to live your life
while the rape and people and how crazy,
how many women had to come out before it
started to fall.
Started it all off.
Our Buddy Hannibal,
Hannibal,
just did a show somewhere and talked
about it on stage and somebody recorded
it.
And then people like,
wait,
Bill cosby raped people,
right?
And like wildfire.
And it spreads through the culture.
But how crazy they like it didn't take
just one woman saying he raped,
right?
It had to be like 16.
Well,
he had settled a bunch of,
a bunch of cases settled.
Um,
close the.
Close the story.
No sealed the records.
Nondisclosure 3 million.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And
now he's suing one of the women who's
testify against them because she's
violating the hush payment.
Oh,
really?
Dark.
So sick of everybody else's sex.
The hello friend is a nod to his son
that was murdered.
It's a memorial to him.
Oh yeah.
There was an article I just found from a
long time ago,
like 1993 that he made a jazz album
dedicated to them called hello friend.
Okay.
Did they ever find who killed us on and
why?
Yeah,
I think they did it like he.
His car broke down,
right?
Yeah.
Like by the four or five or something
and he was like getting out to fix it
and someone killed them.
Was it a.
was it just a random crime or was it a
robbery?
I think it was.
I think it was robbery,
attempted robbery attempt because did he
have a nice car or something?
He had a Mercedes.
So terrible.
What a tragedy in American tragedy.
He's an American tragedy it up across
the board to bottom.
He was so beloved and that's fat Albert
and the cosby show in this standup and
the strangest thing.
Hearing that guy call him.
Dr Cosby.
Do you a doctor anymore?
Yeah,
they think they all took him.
They took that shit back everyone.
Yeah.
Was an honorary doctorate,
right?
Yeah,
right from different schools.
A temple and
nasty and honorary doctorate.
Would you call yourself Dr Papa?
Yeah.
Would you know I'm a minister.
Are you going to.
I'm doing Rachel Feinstein's wedding
show.
Weinstein's wedding next Saturday.
And shut the fuck up my fourth one.
Really?
You've done for.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
He married people graduations.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's really great.
I actually do really love it.
It becomes very real,
very fast.
You know,
I spend a lot of time writing it in,
but once you're up there and two people
are coming and you're doing it,
it's like,
no,
this is a big deal.
This is special.
This is going to be unique and divorced.
It's pretty great.
And then it becomes a disaster.
I had no one that I married is divorced.
Oh,
maybe got the magic touch,
bro.
Yeah.
Maybe you're the secret stuff.
The divorce rate of 50 percent in
America.
That's right.
But uh,
Chris Rock,
I have a joke about it.
He goes,
he goes,
and that's just the people who have the
balls to leave
cowards who stay and suffer.
This is Chris.
This is Chris before he was divorced,
which is kinda really because once he
got divorced he got tay again.
Oh,
really?
Tell.
Hey can.
I don't think he had a prenup.
So he went down hard.
He was onstage.
He goes,
he goes,
my wife made more money last year doing
comedy than Dave Chappelle.
Great Line.
Rough.
It's rough.
It's really rough.
For more money from comedy.
Said.
Geez Louise.
Tough Times out there for people.
GotTa be funny.
Just to enjoy your life.
Make some bread,
make some bread.
Celebrate with your family.
Get a little cabin in the woods.
Salted butter,
little sticky buns.
Why not your show?
We did eight.
Oh,
eight.
And did you have any say over what
cities you chose?
Where'd you go?
Yeah,
we went to New York.
We went to Detroit,
a Los Angeles,
New Orleans,
uh,
cleveland.
Um,
philly.
All good places.
Nice.
All good.
We go in and you just meet these bakers,
these people that are baking stuff and
making amazing stuff.
We do like four or five stops in each
city and they're all just great people.
They're just fun families.
Just,
you know,
making cakes and repeating the community
and it's great.
And do you do with your friends in these
towns?
Like if you new comedians that were in
the town,
did you have them come with,
you know,
just you and Gaffigan came in New York,
so this donut shop and he was the only
friend that came the season,
but uh,
I'd like to do more of that.
That would be fun.
Now you're friends with Seinfeld and
he's a crazy porsche fanatic.
Yeah.
Try to get you to buy a porsche big time
port.
No,
no.
He kind of knows.
I'm not really that big of a car guy.
Have you ever driven one?
I did.
He let me drive one because I'd never
driven it.
It was like a million dollar car,
blue nine something
and it was just in traffic around Santa
Monica.
It was really a bummer.
It was annoying.
It was a million dollar car.
Yeah.
Jesus.
What does a million dollar car the same
as another car,
but they only made one of it.
Oh,
it's an older car.
Yeah,
it was from the seventies I think,
or eighties and it would just,
they'd only made like this was like the
second one or something,
but uh,
no.
It's like if I was into it he would get
on me and stuff.
But,
but you will only need around Santa
Monica.
Like if you get it on open road it would
be amazing.
Do you have a porsche?
Yeah,
I got one out there right now.
If you want to show you do I got a race
car?
A white one up there going.
Oh yeah,
I've seen that.
It does.
Jerry Seinfeld.
I've seen that at the store.
Oops,
that's not what you drove that three,
five,
six.
It's not a million dollar car speedsters
on a million dollar car.
I was probably slash 11 ass.
It was blue.
It's probably a nine slash 11 s from the
seventies.
It was worth a lot of money right now.
An Rs.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I like that one.
That he's got above scroll.
Scroll down.
That white one.
The white one.
Oh,
that they couldn't get in the country
for awhile,
right?
One,
the white one right there.
There you go.
Yeah.
That one.
Wow.
That's a very valuable car.
Yeah.
That's uh,
I asked for an rs from.
That's funny.
Woman backs into Jerry Seinfeld.
She
backed into the car at three point
three.
Five.
Three point three.
What?
Lilian?
Yeah.
She's.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well,
you know when mustangs are going for
500,000.
Well it says no.
No.
Jamie says worth between $14,000 in
three point three.
$5 million for right?
Yeah.
So some lady just backing up
a car.
What's the big deal?
That one of the right hand corner is a
million dollar car below that spider.
Upper right hand.
That one right there.
That's a nine.
18.
Is that the one you drove?
Yeah,
it looks like that.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's a nine.
18.
That's the electric.
Is that Utah pumping?
I'll look.
It looks like me.
It's the blue car that has an amazing
car.
That's a nice hybrid.
That wasn't it ridiculously fast car.
But you just sound interesting to you.
Amazing.
That's just a boxster.
No,
I get into it.
I just don't know all this.
You know,
you gotta spend time like digesting that
are growing up with it and I didn't have
that,
you know,
I like it.
I appreciate it.
I had a nine,
nine,
44 poster in my,
in my,
uh,
in my room.
I remember those.
An engine.
Yeah.
And those were,
you know,
it was more like the best porsches,
but that's what I kind of like a cool
card excited about.
They're very well balanced friend of
mine who drove those on a racetrack.
Oh yeah.
I used to race those.
Nice.
Yeah,
because it's like,
it's a very balanced car.
Right.
He's so deep into it,
like his thing,
it kind of keeps him saying,
I think it's just,
that's where he puts his,
a human.
Jay Leno,
the extra time stuff.
Yeah.
It's kind of funny that they both are
doing car things.
Let us shows good if you've seen it.
It was,
I was on it.
Oh,
you were on it.
Yeah.
What were you doing in 1965?
Corvette Corvette's.
I've 65 corvette.
That's what you call a resto mod.
So the what they do is they take an old
car,
but they put modern suspension and
brakes and a modern engine in it.
Oh Nice.
So it's reliable.
It starts up every time.
It breaks really well in the car.
Guys think that that's not pure so it's
not as good and that kind of thing.
I just like what I like to drive.
It's like to drive an old car and to
keep it old.
It's to me like,
okay,
good luck with that.
You have a good time.
They can till they make it.
So it breaks better yet.
Definitely do that.
Can they make it so it handles better
either they can.
Where would I want to do that?
That's not how they do.
What am I in the Flintstone days?
No breaks.
Just give me a whole.
So I just stick my feet out the bottom.
But they get snobby about that stuff.
They can fuck off.
They do get snobby.
There's a guy,
right?
He lives up the street from me.
Yeah.
I had my car and I was washing it and he
pulled by with the same exact car,
but his was totally stock and he looked
at mine and immediately he could tell
like you looked at the wheels,
a giant fat steam roller tires on it and
I mean it's just modern.
Everything is.
And he lifted the wheels.
He's like,
that's not stock.
And I go,
no,
it's not stock.
And you could see.
He's like shaking his head.
He's like,
when he got in the hood,
I go,
what's a supercharged ls one with 500
horsepower son?
Like when you got that rickety ass
carburetor driven fucking dinosaur
immobile,
PPP.
Fuck out of here with your stock.
Bullshit.
I'll give me the stink eye.
Sorry.
It's funny,
but he really did.
He was looking down at me like weird.
Like you're not a man.
You're fast and handles good.
Yeah.
I want it to be pleasurable to drive.
Of course,
not just stare at you.
Fuck,
goddammit.
It doesn't even have the old frame.
So is everything.
Everything's different.
Even the frame is different.
Yeah,
it's going to modern frame because it's
like it's rigid.
Those old frames through were pulled
together with bubblegum fucking coat
hangers and shit
for real 1965 car on the highway.
You like.
Even my Volkswagen just has a lap belt.
Oh my corvette is a lap belt.
If you ever think about putting the
regular belting.
Nope.
But that you'll keep leaving a laptop.
It's also confused with carnival ride
route if you're lucky.
You get thrown from the car.
How amazing is Leno's garage as though
it's insane garage yet?
He has 11 warehouse building,
airplane hangars filled with huge.
It's like a museum.
It's the craziest Shit I've ever seen.
I didn't know.
Like I knew we had a bunch of cars,
but I didn't know and so I went.
I went down,
I was wandering around.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Maybe he took to my father and I threw
it like let my father come after did
this tonight show and he said,
come on up.
I'll give you a chart.
He was so nice.
I brought my father around and when he
was just blown away.
I mean,
it was,
you go through like miles and miles of
cars and he's like,
you want to see the motorcycles?
What?
Then you go into a whole nother place
and there's just filled with bikes.
He drives everything in there.
It takes everything in there on the
road.
Everything is street legal.
I'm going to take the steam roller and
it takes a fucking steam roller with
like rubber on the tires.
There it is right there.
Knows fucking garage.
It's a crazy place.
It's so crazy.
It's gorgeous.
All the stuff on the walls.
All the memorabilia is insane.
Yeah,
it is gorgeous.
And he has a shop,
like full people.
Their mechanics working on the stuff.
Yeah.
With Three d printers,
making the tools and pieces and yeah,
he can literally make spare parts.
You can machine things.
Look at that.
All from Carmen Jean Shirt on.
Austin Tuxedo.
You add them on,
right?
Yeah.
He's great.
He was great.
It's so interesting hearing him swear.
Right?
Like the people that have you never
heard the Jay Leno episode.
Go listen to it because he tells some
fucking insane stories about doing gigs
for the mob.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
About the mob guys.
Like yelling at priests and like how
intense it was.
Really?
Yeah.
He's been around.
He's done a lot of gigs.
I done a lot of gigs.
He makes all of his.
All of his money for all the cars all
comes from comedy tonight.
Show money.
All went to the bank.
Is that insane?
It's crazy.
Like,
what are you doing with all that money,
Bro?
It's insane.
Guys on tonight show for how many years?
Yeah.
He refused to spend a dime of it.
Throw it all in the bank.
No kids,
no kids.
Just keep all that money.
Just shoot loads.
And whose car is that?
Amazing.
Often comedy.
Look at that.
Yet that front of that car is filled up
with all this backed up.
Come
shooting up slowly into that engine.
I'm sorry,
did you say what runs on?
Just what that card.
That card does.
No,
I'm not a car guy,
but that's weird.
Right?
He takes that around with them.
Imagine that lady was backing up.
He was always on my twitter.
I'm arguing with people that trap,
but million dollar cap.
I saw Jay once when I was in traffic.
I'm a cold water.
I just see this man,
you know,
and it's all backed up in both ways.
It's just tons of traffic.
I see this man like running down the
center of the traffic,
like who's this nut?
And it was jay going,
he goes past the car,
picks up his hubcap that came off and
goes running back the other way.
He probably has to get that hubcaps
probably no other hubcap like it.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
Look at that thing.
Oh my God.
That guy with them.
Some dude.
Oh,
that's richie mic rich.
Rich Richie.
Skinny tires and the fucking thing.
Oh my God.
It's so weird.
It's a good show.
It's so much better for him than the
tonight show in that he gets to be who
he is.
Completely.
One hundred percent passionate about
cars.
He fucking loves cars and he knows
everything about them.
Yeah,
he loves it.
Oh,
that's that 73 Mazda.
That guy was actually there while I was
there.
He was the next one after we filmed my
episode,
he was waiting and he's got this crazy
73 mazda that's like fucking super
souped up.
Really light to see when he rolled are
rolled a card to that video and what did
he roll?
He rolled,
I think it was like a truck.
Seinfeld rolled one of his cars to kind
of like a baby roll.
Seinfeld had a baby role.
Yeah,
I think it was the hospital off the off
ramp.
No,
I don't think it was a big deal.
Really?
Yeah,
I think he went to the hospital.
You almost died.
No.
Oh,
there it goes.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Oh,
it's just a car.
that's a Chevelle.
Is that what is that Super Vee?
It's hard to tell what that is.
You got to know Jesus.
Can you hear it?
His reaction was funny at the end.
No,
it wasn't an accident occurred while the
whole show
that old dude shouldn't be driving.
Yeah.
That's kind of the vibe that you got.
Jay was like,
all right.
I mean it literally one,
two.
What does that got killed?
Jay Leno is too old to drive
the avid current.
Geez.
That seemed like it was a while ago.
It was several years ago,
I think.
Wow.
It's crazy.
That's when this video was put up.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
he gets out.
Can you hear him
until he gets home?
My wife says this,
your wife,
Alicia and old Barracuda.
It's tough to tell what that car is.
Plymouth,
what is that?
It isn't old Barracuda.
Oh Wow.
That's the first model.
Barracuda,
which is a totally different looking
car.
Then the second generation.
Wow.
Body styles differ.
It was a weird looking car.
They're cool though.
Yeah.
It's good to have an obsessive hobby.
It's good in life,
right?
Even if you work hard and do all this
stuff,
that's still extra time to put your
energy into something.
For me,
it's imperative.
Yeah.
I figured that out over the years of my
life.
Like for me,
I need mine,
Carla and flipped once in the comments
that they just edit it.
Tomato look worse.
I'm trying to.
I was replaying.
That's.
Wait a minute.
Play that,
but no more than one.
Play it back for us.
I'm sorry,
some people said they saw the unedited
footage.
Hold on.
Do it again.
Do it from the beginning.
It looks
guys shifting.
Here's the flip.
Oh,
he hit a wheel horsepower.
No way more than 100 horsepower.
Let me see this guy
multiple times.
One to know that they just added the
same clip back in Atlanta that way
after.
Yeah,
I think that's true.
I think they're probably telling the
truth.
I think that thing probably flipped
once.
Whatever,
whatever he wants is rough.
It's hard to get something to flip a
bunch of times,
like you gotta be really flying to flip
a bunch of times,
flip once.
By the time all the energy would be
dissipated by the time he hit bang,
bang pain,
you know,
be careful out there.
Kids don't.
Especially with those old ass cars,
especially old ass cars with old
suspensions.
That's why I juice my shit up with
modern stuff.
Yeah,
take that neighbor,
neighbor,
asshole.
You fucking old drive fucking tires.
Those old crack tiredness goes out.
Old Tires.
No tread.
You need a hobby.
You need stuff.
It's amazing.
Like you could do all this work and like
really hardcore at your career and
there's still extra time.
Well,
not just that.
I think doing one thing only all the
time is not good for the brain.
I think it's good for the brain to be
excited by a bunch of different things.
Interesting.
I think it makes you more person and
makes it more interesting with as a
comic is I think is very important.
It's very important to have a more
nuanced perspective to also have more
information to draw from that.
Like you're,
you're experiencing more different parts
of La and also different types of
failure.
I think different types of failure is
good for you.
Absolutely.
It go failure.
Mental failure,
complication failed.
I think all that stuff's good for
something that you're not good at.
Yes.
It's amazing.
It's amazing how many times you will
feel like a beginner back at the same
thing you've been practicing.
Like if you start making changes,
like,
oh,
I'm kind of back to the beginning of
this again.
What do you do other than the baking?
The baking is the biggest thing.
The baking is like,
it's really like my first hobby.
I never really had something like that.
Yeah.
I put all my time into.
It was always just stand up and then.
And then,
uh,
the baking and now I'm writing more than
ever before.
So I'm like writing,
sitting down,
writing,
concentrated for long periods of writing
comedy or just writing,
writing.
It depends.
You know,
I have that.
I'm the head writer for live from here,
the prairie home companion thing.
And is that garrison keillor?
They kicks him out.
That's the new thing.
Well,
he quits.
He retired before he got in trouble.
He retired a couple of years before.
Oh,
he did?
Yeah.
And that's why the.
But once he got in trouble,
that's when the name of getting in
trouble thing was before he even
retired.
Like it was an incident from both.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
it was an old thing.
It was kind of a muddled thing.
Very weird one.
But when I had said that on the podcast
that it was weird and then he just kind
of hugged a chick and his hand went down
her back.
Then someone sent me an article that
there was more than one incident,
several of them and that he had been and
they didn't make them public and I don't
even know what they were,
but I know they had to.
They did investigate it,
but they had to end up changing the name
of it.
So anyway,
I spent a lot of time writing for that.
Then it went really from writing my book
and then I got that Gig.
So I continued writing at that pace and
uh,
and now I'm continuing to write like
that.
So I,
if the writing is the,
is kind of a,
it's weird because it's from doing
standup writing this,
it almost seems like something new.
It almost seems like another hobby.
Another different way to exercise your
mind.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's different sitting there like
writing stuff out,
like really parsing out.
But it does make me think like,
and I haven't been able to crack it of
like why not put that effort of that
intense writing style into the standup?
You don't do that?
No,
I'll,
I'm looser with it.
I'll write it and they'll go perform it
and then I'll come back and edit it,
but that Carlin did that at the end.
He would just write the whole thing and
memorize it,
you know,
he would like,
like a book and then go present it.
I haven't gotten,
I haven't done that.
I do do that.
That's
the.
No,
no.
What I do is,
um,
I do two things.
One,
I write a premises in word and then I
have a program called scrivener.
Scrivener does is it lets me take things
into prem,
into categories or into subjects.
So I have like,
I'm like,
I have a title of a set,
right?
I'll call it,
like my last special's called the one
that's coming out.
It's called strange times.
So I wrote strange times at the top of
it and then I have all these different
subjects in strange times and then I can
move them around,
I can shift them and each time I click
on one,
it takes me to all the stuff that I've
written about that subject.
And then I also can click on another
little part of it and it shows me a cork
board and on the corkboard is like
these,
um,
which called virtual index cards,
the index cards that I can move around
each index card as like notes on
different parts.
Like this is a very important part of
the bit.
This is a,
this is a note about a study that was
done that shows that this is real,
all these different things and so I can
move those around.
But this way I can look at it in the
little tiny side.
We're all,
each individually individual subject is
all in this one long column and I could
see like the set,
like this is a whole set but then,
but no matter what,
it has to be really ironed out in front
of an audience because I can write as
much as I want.
And a lot of it is effective writing
alone.
But it comes to life in front of an
audience and changes.
Yeah.
But how much will you write before you
bring it out?
Like will you write a couple pages into
it or just
little depends,
you know,
sometimes it's thousands of words for a
couple minute bit.
And you'll take that up before you've
tried it.
You write a thousand?
Yes,
sometimes.
And sometimes it's just a few lines and
then I just run with a premise.
Sometimes I'll just try to try to air a
premise out and see where it goes.
There's one that I'm working on right
now that I have,
so the,
the setup of the premise gets a really
big laugh and that I don't know where to
go with it over here and I'm fucking
around with it and I'm trying to figure
out where,
where to go with Dell or something there
and I'm not going to let it go.
But every day I throw a little bit of
water on it and I hope to see the
sprouts.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
if you've got a great premise,
there's,
there is a great job,
there's something there definitely.
But it's one of those ones where I know,
okay,
I can't let this go.
I know there's something there,
but right now
shit Finna take awhile.
It can be the only one that believes in
this.
I know.
It's amazing.
It's so funny.
I was reading something about a raccoon
the other day.
I saw a raccoon with her hands and I
was.
As I was writing about it,
I was like,
wait a minute,
and I looked through my notes.
It's like I thought I had a really good
raccoon bit a year ago
in the audience told me this wasn't very
good and I ended up quitting on it and
now I'm,
I'm back with my new rec,
let it go and then walk around it,
look at it
from the back and then walk around it,
look at it from the side and then maybe
sometimes something happens and you go,
oh my fucking raccoon bit.
You go through your notes.
Oh
Tom Pop.
It's already 4:00.
Time flies.
Oh my God,
you're crazy the fuck bro.
I know.
When I was coming here I was like,
I don't know if I got three hours in me
today.
That's the last thing you said last time
we were here.
Isn't really,
is it really one of them?
She said,
what are we going to talk about?
We'll just start talking.
It always flies tom population.
Gentlemen on the food channel starting
Monday.
Monday was Monday,
September third and they'll be on every
Monday.
Do a lot of press.
What's that?
Are you doing a lot of press?
Um,
a good amount of press?
Yeah,
I've done a bunch it Mondays.
Ten PM,
nine central,
1:30 PM.
Comedy and bread.
Fuck.
That's all you need.
Hey,
your audience made it happen for real.
Well,
thank you brother.
Thanks for being here.
Always Great.
Good luck with your show.
I'm a hope it runs forever.
Bread.
Do you have any elk slavery's?
I do.
I've got a shitload but freezer bags.
Sweet.
Yes.
Bye everybody.
See you next week.
You fucks.
Love Ya.
Bye.